e
e e
I for
that brother-in-laws I I'm gonna try and
P into it and see about using
those good morning
everybody um might as well get started
we have um uh a number of bills today I
think six bills today um and just uh an
update for your information um
representative Noble just checked and we
are now up to 63 bills um assigned to us
so um yeah still not more election no
that's true
right um but we're making good progress
and um you know we'll have some uh busy
weeks and hopefully uh that week of um
school vacation um you know we'll be
able to take off I
hope so uh that's okay our um first bill
today is House Bill
362 uh granting the Department of
Education rule making authority to
require candidates to obtain passing
scores on professional education um
sounds like a little bit of a familiar
title um uh this is Representatives Lads
Bill and he's here and um this is
actually uh representative lad day in
terms of hearings yeah um he wasn't
doing anything else today so we figured
we'd give him something to
do um so welcome uh representative lad
um and we are interested in hearing
about HB
362 well thank you very much uh
representative cordelli chair cordelli
and members of the education policy
committee whatever you want
Administration what you want to call it
um this chair is a big chair you know
you can get lost in this thing and your
wings have to be that wide to move it
around there's all I put two of us in it
um I'm here today to introduce I guess
reintroduce the the concept that we have
in in front of us this is HB
362 and apparently there was a you know
a parallel situation or a parallel
universe over at legislative Services
the day that representative cordelli put
his in I put mine and um they're danal
and and so I do not want to go through
and rehearse all this for you again but
just giving you rather than walking
through that bill because it's a very
short bill um this is an area that we
I'm talking we as a legislature have
always been very um cautious of our lure
in this state in terms of that the bar
due to what covid or years before
anything else is going on doesn't lessen
we still want our our our folks in the
classrooms teaching based upon a certain
standard that our state board of
education has adopted and
approved and that's basically the
concept behind this whole thing here we
do not want as some states are now
doing they're lessening the requirements
to become a licensed
educator that puts up red flags for me
uh I was in my previous life a fourth
grade teacher after I came out of the
service there was this young Lieutenant
that came out and said I need to get a
job and I love working with people I had
worked at Maine Military Academy as an
instructor there and seen it all
overseas um so I got in that business
and I saw the professionalism of
teachers in the
classroom and then following that I got
in into school principal ship and
supervising what I saw in classes in
curriculum and instruction ction and
stayed with that the rest of my working
life and ended up in Alaska where I was
at the Distinguished Principal that year
for the entire State and the reason why
I see this as an important bill is that
we do need to maintain our standards in
New Hampshire we need to maintain New
Hampshire
standards and for lure and when I see
what's being tried down in New Jersey
when I see what's being proposed in the
state of Maine are neighbors and when I
started out in the business of Education
the university Maine and University of
New Hampshire worked collaboratively
together Maine did not have a physical
therapy program yet UNH did so we had
people going back and forth where the
programs were and so but the standards
which this state has are no longer the
same as what Mains ours are higher and
they deserve to be there and that's
because the we we're when you look at
our achievement scores in this country
where does the where do state of New
Hampshire really Stack Up in proportion
I'm not saying we're perfect we have a
long way to go in mathematics and some
of those basic subject areas but we're
on top of that list you were in the top
five in the country that's because we
have standards and so I'm not ready to
default to some National Standard or to
some other state let's keep it Hampshire
let's keep the granite state strong
where we are I can remember one day I
was over at doe and I heard this Ruckus
out in the
hallway I don't know if Mr applebe was
there on that particular day I I I
thought Paul leather was there as well
the Deputy
Commissioner and there's this young lady
out there saying why can't I get my
certification why can't I be licensed in
the state all I want to do is teach
kindergarten well the license was a K
through 8 license and as a school
administrator I often saw the
demographic of my schooling up and down
and people moved you mooved where your
demographic moves you might have a
combination class or you may say I need
somebody can teach this and I look at
your staff and and the principal makes
that decision you're now going to be a
sixth grade teacher and in my school we
had sixth grade kids Believe It or Not
were in
pre-algebra not all of them but we when
we taught math in that School everybody
taught math including the PE teacher the
music teacher Etc this young lady if IID
wanted to use her in some other level
and that she couldn't have done it but
she was arguing I can't pass that
practice okay then what are you going to
do about it you're going to maybe go
back to nhti and and and or maybe get in
involved with the math learning
communities program so I think it's
important that if you're going to have
that lure that type of certification
then you're you're you have to meet our
standards and our standards are we want
kids coming out of high school that can
get a job in career have a pathway now
the one thing that I understand that
this this bill may need to address a
little bit more and understand
representative cordelli has a amendment
to it which and I don't care which one
you use 440 or this one it doesn't make
a bit of difference to me I just want to
see our state maintain where we are our
standards when it comes to Career
Technical ucation representative Cornell
you're very involved with that as well
um we recognize that there's trades that
are very very important try to find a
plumber try to find an
electrician I had my my wife had the
stove go out the other day it's a gas
stove you know the oven course is run by
electricity and or not electric gas but
the panel showed cf2 on it I said what
is cf2 you know that's where all the
numbers come up where the timer is and
all this and she's pretty good at it I
just love eating the stuff that comes
out of it
and we had to find out what cf2 meant
and it meant that the the motherboard
behind this stove up top had to be
replaced or it told you you have to go
to this place of course they don't give
you a manual you have to get on the web
to find that out and I want folks coming
out that have the ability that are
working in the trades to be professional
in that industrial area that that
content area that they need the practice
may not be the equipment to do that to
for the assessment we may want to look
at some other type of assessment that's
why we're not saying practice in this
thing we're saying assessment so if
there needs to be some more definition
done through um the uh folks over at doe
I'm all for it because we need to have
instructors in our our CTE programs the
know about Plumbing that know about the
the electrical part that I mentioned
earlier and if you have 30 years there
and you're coming in from Napa and you
have Nappa certification in certain
areas and you have this understanding
about the content and
skills Concepts behind it that's the
person I want fixing my car not the guy
that's learned everything out of a book
and never really practiced it uh there's
that little thing we call OJT on the job
training if you have a lot of good
experience I'm good for it so but we
still want to maintain those standards
for the classroom teachers and
and so I I support doe and their efforts
to do this this bill is brought To Us by
them so I I'll conclude that you've had
this spill before so I'm not going to go
there I want to thank you very much and
good
luck thank you uh chairman lad uh any
questions uh yes representative Woodcock
true if I may Mr chair the first one to
comment that F2 means buy your wife a
new
stove yeah and I I I don't know if they
sell them right up in Conway uh that
type I was looking for but uh and
they're not cheap that's true the the
second part I made Mr chair yes um Rick
on on your part about 10 11 and 12 when
we're talking about CTE in 440 and the
the bill we had yesterday it allowed for
uh the basic academic skills or an IND
an industry recognized certification uh
as the option but in
your uh 362 it just talk more about the
waiver and it doesn't have that minimum
so it
reduces as I look at it it reduces the
requirement for CTE professional uh
vocational instructors by taking away
any industry piece and just a waiver so
I didn't know what the thinking was
there we have worked on the uh CT
advisory Council and there's an effort
there we've looked at certification and
we we we we made recommendations on that
and we know it's very difficult to find
these people in to work in our CTE
programs they're competing with industry
and obviously there's more money in the
industry side of that I'm all for uh
maintaining a high level focus of
Standards if you were to talk to the
directors of the CTE centers I think
they support that that's a lot of this
langine which you're seeing that's
coming from doe has come by way of uh Mr
Jeff beards who is the person who works
with it so if this is going to come out
from doe for that need for that
amendment I do support it uh I support
their efforts they recognize that uh CTE
are not exactly the same as teaching
social studies in the classroom um
there's a lot of pedagogy that they have
to have I will agree on that sh
clarification yes follow up I understand
that my my concern I understand that my
concern is and I appreciate CTE stuff
um my concern is that you in your bill
you've re we've taken out the phrase
that allowed the industry recognized
credential and that and I think that's
what we're both talking about is that if
you have an industry credential that
that would be fine but in your bill
that's gone it just talks about the
waiver and I see I was leaving it more
open for the the rules to make that
decision industry type credentials they
they vary and as you know uh we have
Folks up at White Mountain Community
College uh getting that degree and
Welding okay and when they come out of
that CTE program they're assessed on the
industry standard by a person that's a
member of that Association so uh you
might have a different standard and
different way it's issued um you might
be able to get it out of aerial box I
don't know but at any rate I I think
that we need to make sure those
standards and I'm not the person that
equipped to make that decision I was
trying to leave it open so through the
rul making process which come back to
Jael car Steve can do his job than sure
uh any further questions of
Representative
lad uh seeing none thank you um I see Mr
applebe from the Department is here um
maybe we can have him come forward
because I think that there were
additional conversations At Doe about
these bills um after our hearing
yesterday
thank you Mr chair good morning uh
members of the committee Steven appy
director Department of Education hope
everyone is well this morning um I had
proposed some uh wording changes to an
amendment to 440 from yesterday which is
substantially similar to the bill um
introduced this morning and that
Amendment would address um several uh
items some of which came up here
yesterday in test in questioning and
testimony and the other um just to be
more precise for CTE so um I I have
supplied a copy of that Amendment um but
essentially it would it would add the
word initial in front of New Hampshire
license which would take care of
Representative woodcock's question and
and so now it it clearly says initial
lure not um seeking it's seeking an
initial license so that is much clearer
um the I've also um added language
specifically exempting CTE teachers from
this
requirement and then modifi the language
that talked about industry recognized
credential because the way that the bill
upon um one of my folks came to me
yesterday and said you know the way this
reads it could be interpreted as this
and what I mean by that is um the way
the original wording read it talked
about basic academic skills
testing but this bill is also talking
about content testing
and it wasn't clear that a CT teacher
would be exempt from content testing the
way the original language was written so
we've we've gone ahead and clarified
that in the amendment um and also but
left in that language about basic
academic skills testing and Industry
recognized credential just to codify
that that is the current practice today
in administrative rule but it's not in
statute so represent Marie thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question I
I do have an additional question if
there you said initial like sure with
regard to CTE or or traditional like uh
academic classroom settings um in the
event that somebody were to pursue an
additional type of CTE program such as
they were going from um like an
automotive to some other Science and
Technology sort of CTE program would you
require a separate certification for
them moving from
one to another yes so non C that's a
simple answer they have chemistry they
want biology they have to apply for
another endorsement on their license CT
is a little different in that we have a
CT specialty um endorsement and that
tends to cover a lot of these things so
um many times they wouldn't have to
apply there are instances but it's much
much less common than it would be in the
academic subject
areas representative Cel thank you so
much um so you referenced an amendment
do we have copies of that not yet uh
just got it last night um so yeah we can
uh easily um amend one of these bills
and uh you know maybe it all the other
um you know we'll take a look at getting
that done next week okay thank
you representative Woodcock thank chair
Mia thank you for being here again today
and particularly for listening to our
comments yesterday and and and helping
us with that U I'm looking at representa
lad's Bill uh 361 and I just want to
make them sure part about the CTE w
pretty much then uh negates uh in the
440 line that talked about the economic
skills and the the industry the industry
credential so am I understand you to say
that's what you
prefer thank thank you for the question
um I I guess what we would prefer is to
not conflate basic academic skills tests
assessment tests with content assessment
so we wanted to carve
out um an exemption for CTE regarding
the content exams okay and then add the
language keep the language to talk about
industry recognized credential and basic
academic skills and the waiver okay or
the substitution I should say of IRC yes
thank you so that that's the amendment
that represent cordelli is talking about
okay thank you both
right any further questions C on thank
you very much thank you and um yeah we
will uh schedule the exec session for
both bills and uh put the amendment on
to one of these and uh possibly it all
the others and uh knock off to uh uh two
bills um and I'm not I our schedule is
already in for next week so it probably
be the the following week that we would
do
that so if anyone has any other thoughts
um you know just let us know about those
two bills um so I'll conclude the
hearing on uh House Bill 362 and we have
a few minutes um until our next uh bill
hb90 on part-time
teachers
e
e e
well the one clock on the wall anyway
says uh 10:45 so uh we'll um get started
with the next uh bill was which is
hb90 relative to the definition of
part-time teachers and um representative
lad is back
again well thank you again
representative cordelli and members of
the committee I'm here or first of all
I'm Rick lad I come from hav New
Hampshire that's uh Grafton 5 and I'm
here today to present House Bill uh 90
this is a bill relative to definition of
part-time
teachers and I'd like to give a little
background just why did this bill come
about it came about last year we had a
bill which was much broader than what it
is right here you're going to look down
on this and you're going to see that
there's
items which uh really Define what a
part-time teacher can be under this
section of law and the prior that it was
wide open it had almost the connotation
that you could take a person of this
character background content knowledge
and put them in the classroom and they
be full-time that's not where this bill
is this bill is specifically
designed and it came about during the
committee of conference which we had
last year where we came out a committee
conference and all approved
it but the bill didn't become have the
opportunity to go forward because some
of those that approved it never signed
off on
it so here we are now part-time teacher
why well we have a program we call
concurrent enrollment in the state
that's where a high school student in
grades 10 11 and 12 has the
opportunity if they meet all the
prerequisites and if they're
eligible to take
courses that will also give them
graduation credit as well as credit in a
college level course that's what we call
concurrent that's taught by a high
school teacher dual enrollment is where
it's taught by a individual from the uh
College in the college
system when we have the course taught in
the high school by a local teacher they
have to meet the standards they have to
meet the standards of the accrediting O
organization Nei that accredits the the
school like I'll say nhti the community
college system you have to meet those
standards for what this how who teaches
this course you have to have a
master's you have to have this type of
material that's approved the syllabus is
approved it has to meet that Collegiate
standard that's the same material that's
used in the concurrent enrollment
program down in the high schools the
unfortunate thing
is we have some high
schools that do not have a person
teaching for example mathematics or a
stem subject that has a
master's and we had that occur we have
that occur in in Manchester we have that
occurring in Franklin and both of those
communities are communities that I hear
in the committee that I have and I heard
many many years here we don't have the
funding to really meet all our needs and
we have some excellent teachers that are
certified licensed that have bachelor's
degrees but they have a wealth of years
the wisdom that's necessary the content
is needed the concepts that are needed
to teach mathematics
so what happened in nhti working with
Chancellor Rubenstein and those over
there at
nhti we were working out a
situation where a professor or an adun
could come from the community college
system to Franklin or to Manchester and
teach that
course the problem is that individual
who may have a PhD and
Mathematics are just the Masters but
years of experience teaching students to
become teachers or teaching within the
math
department doesn't have
certification issued by the doe to teach
in the high
school how do we get around that how do
we authorize that individual to come
down and work in that school where the
school doesn't have a Master's level
teacher to provide that concurrent
enrollment course why not use these
folks which the un uh the community
college system New Hampshire is anxious
and very supportive to do and willing to
do
that and you have those receiving
talents also willing to pay the
professors coming down to do
that but they don't have
certification so what this bill does it
enables that individual coming out of
the Collegiate level to come down and
teach that kid those students that would
really benefit from this course to also
at the same time receive concurrent
enrollment and that's
important we have students that are
graduating from our high schools that
have gone through this program Dual and
concurrent rollment in 10th Grade 11th
grade and 12th grade and they they've
taken up to those four courses each year
multiply that times the number of
courses they could they come out with a
semester worth of Education that's going
to prepare them with all the Gen gened
courses that you have to have at the
Collegiate level that's a huge savings
when we calculate the savings that
concurrent to on romance providing the
state it's over $10
million of later costs when we can get
this student that course for 150 bucks
verse three times that at the community
college system or if they take it at the
University it's a whopping a lot
more
so the issue is I'm trying to enable our
students to get a program which is going
to better prepare them for their career
and pathway so looking specifically at
this bill why did we put down 20 hours
that they come down and they can teach
for a maximum of 20 hours per
week you and I know that it's basically
five five and a half hours of
instructional time that's stretching it
in a high school four four courses me
four for blocks or whatever and you look
at the grade schools the middle schools
the same thing and so if you multiply
times five 5 hours or five and a half
times the 5 days per week and you see
that 30 hours if we put down 30 hours
they could probably come down and tee
fulltime that's not what we're trying to
aim to do I'm not trying to
circumvent staff that are properly
certified and licensed in all those
areas and we're not trying to cut cost
by doing that no we're trying to provide
opportunity for all students here and
this is one way we can do it especially
when we're talking about those content
areas stem and Mathematics and Science
this is where that college level person
the adjunct or the professor associate
professors can come down and do this we
are not talking about coming down and
teaching in a course like special
education we cannot do that if you're
receiving money through the elementary
secretary Education Act Essa or if
you're you're you're in the area of
special education or ELO that by federal
law does not allow us to do
this those content areas have to be
taught in conjunction with those fedal
dollars which were coming down whether
it's by law or Federal Regulation or
federal code this program is not aimed
at those types of instructors going to
the next
line do they have to have a criminal
background check yes yes they do we
don't want anybody in a
classroom with our minor students 18
years old or
younger in a classroom with an
individual we don't want anybody in a
classroom that hasn't had a criminal
background check I think we all agree on
that this all part-time Bill only is
applicable only
applicable if you look at Roman three
they are employed or contract as a
full-time or adjunct faculty member by a
university system of New Hampshire or
the community college system of New
Hampshire that's the only place this
part-time authorization can be issued so
we're talking now only only seven
community
colleges we're talking about UNH
including Manchester and the law school
we're talking about PMA State University
and K keing State College over on the
river those are the only places where
this part-time authorization can be
issued so in the last thing they're also
bound they're Bound by the code of
ethics and the code of conduct that's
written into this law that was as a
result of our discussions in committee
last
year so looking at the code of ethics
and the code of conduct they are
responsible to the
student they're responsible to their
profession and those that are working in
the
profession the responsible to their
community and they're responsible to the
use of Technology that's the fourth
title within those codes of of ethics
and then you look at the codes of ethics
and conduct and you'll see the
principles which are listed below and
the which the code of ethics is
aspirational and then you have the other
side of the code which is more conduct
oriented in actions that are
taken and they are regulated by Ed
rules so I think we've got that covered
very very much so that they the
part-time person is going to be account
they're going to have to have the bars
not
lessened I for one would really
appreciate that the person that taught
me geometry and that's where I learned
much my math but that's a subject I love
had come with the knowledge that a
college professor that I met who really
got it into me after I graduated from
high school um that person didn't have
certification but per that person was in
the profession for a long time and knew
his stuff so at that Mr chair I will
stop my
presentation
and take any questions you may have uh
thank you very much uh yes
representative Hall thank you Mr chair
and thank you uh representative lad for
taking my question so I'm just wondering
in the in a scenario of let's say I
teach at UNH and I teach fashion design
and bigh needs an algebra teacher for
two periods a day can they hire me for
that I guess I I don't see anything in
the here about content so or you you'd
be coming down not with a fashion
degree uh profession to teach you know
pre-calculus calculus trig uh that
person it's going to be teaching that
through the concurrent enrollment
program is going to have to meet those
standards that the accrediting
organization not necessarily what
your Department of Education state board
of education has Lish yes but the
standards of Nei for accrediting that
institution you're coming from and the
department you're coming out of they
need to meet those standards that are
going to be you know used to if you're
going to be from your students going to
transfer from UNH to be a black bear
over Main and that's going a good
direction but um I'm a main graduate but
I think that the that the the things
you're going to transfer have to be uh
transferable and they have to be
measured by the same standard that's
what Nei is all about so no you're
coming down with the wrong credential
and your college is not going to let you
do that anyways and certainly Franklin
or Manchester are not going to welcome
you to come in and teach that Master's
level
course in in the content area you don't
have the background in okay thank you
representative Freeman thank you Mr
chair thank you representative lad for
taking my question and testifying in
front of us today so I need some
clarification um this is not looking to
replace or displace any full-time
District employees is that correct
that's correct so this is just to
augment a program that's already
existing to ensure that the program is
successful and the students are
receiving what they're signing up for
that is also correct what we're doing
we're supplementing that program we know
that there school districts in a
state a wealthy District might be right
beside a poverty-driven district the
wealthy District may have all kinds of
AP
courses they may have all kinds of
courses which are going to lead towards
those degrees that they're going after
the poorer District doesn't have the
Personnel sometimes they're looking to
VX where they can get that for that
course but isn't it always better to
have a class where you can see the
whites of the person's eyes just
teaching you and working with you and
answer your questions and your needs and
address those needs yes that's what this
does provide but they're coming in to
supplement enrich and provide the
opportunity to all
children and this is what the city of
Franklin sees and this is what they'd
like to do what we're trying to do is
make that all possible for them and I as
a university of uh New Hampshire trustee
support this program 100% And I will
continue to advocate for it on the
trustee board thank you yes uh represent
Murray uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I did have a
question regarding enumerating the um
part-time uh hours per week in statute
is that potentially circumnavigating
board level negotiations and District
level negotiations for employment
what we're trying to do is align the
need for this with and of course
bargaining Agreements are different from
place to place we're not trying to usurp
we're just trying to put in a standard
which will allow this to occur so um I
don't think there's any effort here I
think there's more of an effort to try
and work with various
associations that are anxious to see
students uh
offer that opportunity so I don't see it
as trying to circumvent I see it as an
opportunity to uh provide and working
with uh I as a prior teacher myself and
as a prior supervising administrator of
of curriculum and instruction our
primary goal is to meet the standards
and the mission of Education in the
state open up your your statutory uh
books the annotated version the first
the first um section you will see is
where it spells out education is a
shared
responsibility of all the
organizations and parents and school
districts and the community it's a
shared responsibility so um I think we
need to work together here um and I I'm
I'm sure that um this would be the per
the the perspective of those schools
which don't have the ability to do the
concurrent enrollment because they don't
have a master's teacher in the area of
chemistry follow thank you and thank you
for taking my question you're welcome I
do have one followup is isn't it
possible that a district can determine
that part-time might be outside of that
scope and and those negotiations are
something that happened in by District
if if the school board and the district
decides this is out of the scope they
don't have to do
this this is the the concurrent dual
enrollment person coming out of the
Collegiate level is coming down upon
invitation from the receiving District
which would be your District so if your
District decides we don't involvement
with this program fine but there are uh
districts out there right now including
Manchester who would love to have this
opportunity to do this so it's again a
local decision uh if your board says we
don't want that it violates the
negotiated agreement then that's
it represent
Mor thank you Mr chair um so my only
question here is if a teacher Works 20
hours per week for a public school and
then 20 hours a week for a private
school would they still be exempt for
the
credentials by the private school are
you talking about a k through 12
situation correct no because they have
to be fulltime they have to be an
adjunct or a full-time person at the
University system or the community
college system so then then that's going
to they're the it's going to be the
Collegiate levels that authorize this to
happen uh rent s thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I
actually have two questions if I may my
my first one um says you've talked about
this as specifically addressing the
issue of concurrent class class ES or
classes that are dual enrollment and I I
have a child who's currently enrolled in
those as we speak and is in her final
exam for one of them um I don't see in
here in your build specificity of
language that says this is strictly for
teachers who teach only those concurrent
or dual enrollment classes so you know
does that open the spill up so that
someone who might be certified um as a
culinary arts instructor comes and
teaches culinary Arts at the high school
or teaches kindergarten for that matter
for a part-time kindergarten program I I
I don't see where it's specific to only
teaching the concurrent dual enrollment
classes where that is where you're
saying that there's a need that's my
first question yeah oh this program is
designed for the personid to come down
and uh teach the college level course so
they're not going to be coming down in
doing kindergarten because kindergarten
everything you need to learn is learned
in kindergarten so from A to Z and it's
all day long uh so we're not going to
send somebody to come down and be a
full-time teacher in kindergarten or a
first grade or second grade or third
grade this is going to be aimed
primarily at those content areas and
that's what it was designed to do uh
where students don't have that
opportunity to receive that biology
class or or not biology maybe it's just
a highlevel mathematics that's going to
give them that college credit so
followup so for followup so partly I'm
wondering whether we need to just amend
this to put the specificity that it is
exclusively for those dual enrollment
college level classes and my other
question associated with it is where you
talked about the teacher The District in
Manchester saying they don't have
sufficient funds to cover the cost of
Master's level teachers wouldn't it make
more sense for us to increase State
funding to our public school system so
that they can afford to do that so
you're not talking to the chair of the
funding
committee yeah I hear you uh first of
all
um on on the first portion of your
question there I if you see an area
which you think it's going to really
strengthen this program and speak
directly to those content areas I'm open
to any kind of recommendations to come
out of the
committee th this is not my bill this is
a bill which is designed and was
crafted kind of like on the 11th Hour
the 11th day 11th month in committee
conference last year um but it came as
result
of input from the Department of
Education and obviously from the
community college system so yes uh if
you can strengthen the bill um I'd go
for it um what was the second part the
this part money money yeah yeah I didn't
want to talk to money thank you
representa Hall um
the money is an issue this year for us
all and I don't want to get really off
course there we are working diligently
are trying to address that we recognize
that there are
communities which are property poor
communities that cannot provide this we
have known
this for years and we have chipped away
at the seams for a number of years as
well that was the whole intent behind of
the right hand side of the funding
formula where we're looking at the
extraordinary needs Grant
monies are in many communities right now
due to increasing assessed property
values and the tax rate and all changing
and I don't want to go down in too deep
here that we're going we're watching
we're looking at that right now that's
what I spent all morning yesterday
dealing with folks on so we're we're
trying to address that issue we're also
dealing with the issue that we know our
revenues are not catching up with some
of our
needs thank you represent woodcock
thank you CH re lad welcome back again
uh a couple questions to follow up to
and I had the the question as the uh my
counterpart down here about your
dialogue specifically identify
concurrent or dual enrollment classes
and it's not it's not Amplified here um
I'm not suggesting that it doesn't open
the door or other things but that's
that's your your dialogue in the
presentation was just that interesting
you said hesis hesis means stand still
this is not standing still is moving
forward with a wonderful little piece
there the um the other question I do
have is if there's two pieces uh on the
SE eight Letter's lines eight and nine
okay I I don't have that but you just me
the Roman that's okay um one was it says
the employed to contracted by I'm
wondering if it should be
currently uh if I was employed as a
adjunct at Manchester Community College
was employed does that mean I can do
this now it doesn't say that that's the
first question um and secondly
you're implied that the community
college or the university system has to
allow this because you're saying that
they're coming down they have to allow
this from the college there's nothing
here that says that the community
college or the university system has to
allow this to happen as I as I read this
bill it just says if I if I'm employed
they are employed does say currently but
they are employed U which may assume
currently uh by either one of the
institutions I have the right to come
down and do that by a Schoolboard
doesn't say I have to get permission
from the University system so if I'm
teaching one adjunct night course in
Psychology at uh Manchester Community
College that means under this piece it
doesn't matter what Manchester Community
College says to me because I've met
their guidelines I have the right to go
down to teach at kenon high school um
under this bill is that correct yeah
there are two questions there and the
first one uh can somebody who was in the
community college system no longer there
they're retired Etc the this is not past
tense it's R they so uh we're talking
about they have to be employed currently
currently now that's how I read that by
the the U the verb of being there are
the second point there they dealing with
permission uh and and and credit is
issued by the uh community college
system and the way this program is now
changed the administration of this
program is not done through doe any
longer it's done by the community
college system the monies go directly to
and the re reimbursement is done through
there other words we appropriate the
dollars and they go to the community
college system so before somebody's
going to get involved with coming down
the the community college system is
going to be aware that this has happened
and they have the capability saying yay
or nay as to this person's coming down
the request comes from the city of
Manchester or the city of Franklin or
could be a community a town to the to
the um community college system saying
we don't have somebody that has a
master's do do you have somebody that
can and there's going to be approval
from the community college to authorize
that person to come
down te okay thank you thank you for
that um but it then goes back to the the
question that was generated earlier so
is it specifically I understand that
you're saying now I just can't go down
to the high school even though I teach
ad I have to go through the system apply
there I understand that the school
system has to ask do you have any staff
that could do that but you are you
specifically talking about concurrent
and dual enrollment classes or you
talking about any classes
the the program we have right here is
designed because you you have to have a
master's level program so what what this
program's designed around is the
concurrent dual enrollment program to
get college credit at the same time
you're taking this course if we were
having a person come out of Sno for
example they don't have to come out with
a a masters they they can do this
concurrent dual enrollment through
through a person with a bachelor's
degree we have a higher standard in this
state with our Public Schools so uh I
hope that helps you that addresses it
well more okay you know I know just a
comment it doesn't address it represent
lad because it didn't answer the
question the question was does the
person have to be taking classes in a
concurrent or dual enrollment
program if that's what this all if
that's all this is that's terrific
that's exactly what this is all about
that well then
amend it to say that thank you president
Murray thank you for taking my question
and thank you um also um so I'm curious
about whether or not this also
potentially puts a a district and a
college or university system in conflict
or communication with one another about
any rollups and benefits of who is
supposed to be paying for them if this
is a 20 hour per week as it's stated in
statute like I'm just not sure can you
speak to the the paying of this person
comes down Franklin's willing to pay
them to come down during their
time uh however the university system is
going to also receive that $150 for that
course because it's it's a it's
accredited through the accrediting
organization it's authorized through
them the university system has community
college system has to approve uh what's
going on they have to ensure that that
curriculum is in align with the
standards that the Community College set
you just can't call them say hey I have
this course that I'd like to have you
have send somebody down to teach they're
going to say I want to look at that
syllabus I want to look at that
curriculum make sure it parallels what
we do at the Collegiate level if it
doesn't you're not going to get this
person coming
down one question could this I'm sorry
could this be used this language in this
bill um to address uh schools where
there is a teacher shortage for instance
uh teaching uh an AP Math course or
Advanced algebra or something like that
oh this is where you could have if
you're going to do the concurrent dual
enrollment process I think that'd be
great there the teacher shortage is we
we had had a committee dealing with
shortage here several years back and
this is a real problem there's areas we
know where those shortage areas are
although you can talk to director app
will be behind me he says we we've
issued more licenses in the state than
ever before um and so in some areas that
there's a shortage nationally it may not
be in our state but we do know that
there are certain programs that we have
huge shortages in and Career Technical
education is crying for some of these
areas and they also offer career Uh
current dual enrollment at CTE centers
which is
wonderful but we do have those shortage
areas try to find somebody that's
inversed in in in some of those Sciences
we want taught the AP level when I was
an administrator up in Alaska I couldn't
keep them in my district I had Arco and
BP anybody that came in with a degree in
biology or or geology or chemistry was
just sucked right up by them and they
could triple the salary of that person
just in in you know the matter they walk
in the door and so there is a shortage
we're trying to compete and we're trying
to compete
with salaries that we're paying here are
far below what industry and I and I I
recognize that I saw it I i' I've felt
it um I find a good chemistry teacher
that's going to be willing to come in on
board and start with a salary of
$425 which is the average beginning
salary at the low side they're not going
to do
it yes represent Cornell
thank you chair so chair cordelli just
asked if they could come and teach an AP
class and now I'm confused because I
think you said yes they could go teach
the AP class but what if the AP class is
not part of the current end dual
enrollment it's a good question
representer Cornell and I I think that
what you ought to do is ask the
department that question um
the for it's my understanding when we
designed this it was for the the the C
concurrent dual enrollment program we
have AP courses but you know the
standards for AP courses you know I have
two grandkids right now that are in a
school taking nothing but AP courses but
some of the folks are teaching that are
not just Master's level they're
bachelor's people that are teaching some
of those AP courses and they're doing a
great job but that but and it's not in
the state it's at St Johnsbury Academy
and and so um that's a good question you
might redirect that to the department um
I I believe that the AP courses do not
have the you have to have a master's
teach I I don't believe that's the
case represent Woodcock than represent
Corell this is this is um sort of yours
to you
um your your question as I interpreted
it was opening this to um um all teacher
shortage areas which you dialog last
couple years as as an Avenue of success
for Teacher shortage um and I understand
that okay and I heard representative lad
saying sort of vacillating on that piece
um as compared to what this intent of
the bill is so if the intent of the bill
and I'm guessing an amendment is to just
specifically concurrent of dual
enrollment then that's one function but
the intent is to go where you were
talking I think um and trying to help
the entire State on teacher shortage is
a whole different uh dialogue and I just
was that where you were going with that
I I was just asking the question I'm not
a the sponsor or a co-sponsor okay well
okay thank you for the
clarity representative Murray thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question for my own I I'm curious do do
VX programs offer concurrent or dual
enrollment courses to and would this
affect that
program I I can't answer that for you I
I I've never had that question posed to
me and I'm VX is a charter school run by
the state um they're they're widely used
I I know that they can they can do some
high level courses like
AP but I I do not know about going
crossing over the line and the other
courses I've been talking
about there they're they're they're not
they're not the university system
they're not the community college system
and that was the in my getting involved
with this bill initially was trying to
make that Avail these types of courses
that these folks are presently teaching
at the college level available to those
districts which don't have the Personnel
that can do this then don't meet those
national standards or our state
standards I'll correct that that we
require to have a master's
program yeah Ros s thank you and thank
you for indulging me in one more
question um I'm I'm just wondering
hypothetically couldn't someone who's an
adjunct with this bill an adjunct at one
of like nhti or one of the other schools
apply for a part-time position at any
school based upon this to teach any
course as a way for school districts to
hire a part-time and avoid having to pay
someone a full-time salary with then
you're you're getting into another
domain here where they're becoming an
employee of the school district and then
they're going to have to work with the
folks behind me here to get proper
certification licensure this is just
trying to get authorization to teach for
those that are coming down to help out
in these courses I've spoken to so if
they're going to become a part-time
employee here and a part-time employee
there I I think you're you're you're
crossing over on the side where this
this this particular legislation
wouldn't cover that but is it clear this
doesn't sorry thank you it I'm I'm just
trying to figure out how this would stop
that from happening because it it's not
clear to me from what you've written in
here I'm I'm getting a little bit lost
in your question here because you're
talk to say okay they a part-time person
at the as an adjunct at the University
system but they are you know work there
as is stated right here um which which
they are employed to contract as a
full-time or adun members so would you
like they're not going to be part-time
at the University level they got to be
full-time can I clarify what I'm asking
so say for example I was hired by Great
Bay Community College to work for them
you know and I I'm employed by them
because I'm a master's level right
teacher um and I'm teaching all of my
classes for them in the evening for
evening
structure and then the Dober School
District posts a 20 hour a week position
teaching
English so there's this doesn't stop me
from or teaching I don't know Spanish
not that I speak Spanish um other than
get me in trouble but um you know does
this do anything to
stop it seems like this gives do a way
to hire me without my having any
certification in that other subject area
because I'm teaching full-time at the
University in the at the community
college in the
evening without my needing to have the
same level of
certification so that's that's I'm
trying to make sure figure out how this
doesn't permit
that I'm I'm I'm trying to I'd have to
take your question and think a little
bit more about it before I shoot off the
cuff here on that um I I believe that if
they're going to be a full-time employ
employee whether it be during the day or
night they're a full-time employee
coming over and working then
part-time they're working nights they'd
have to do full part-time during the day
maybe in the morning um it's um it's
possible they could be doing that uh I
don't but they to come in and be working
as a part-time they'd have to meet those
conditions and those standards set by
the Department of
Education the State Board
education see no more questions thank
you very much representative lad we have
a couple more people yeah who would like
to
testify um starting with Brian Hawkins
thank you very much
just checking the clock to make sure
it's still good morning uh good morning
Mr chairman uh for the record Brian
Hawkins representing uh Nea Hampshire uh
we represent uh in first time before the
newly minted uh education policy
committee um we repres for those of you
who don't know we
represent uh School staff ranging from
teachers to par professionals to various
support roles uh we o do represent some
higher education as well so um I'll I'll
try to
um to skip over some of the comments
that I think have have been addressed
but hopefully I can address some of the
some questions um any ANH is opposed to
House Bill 90 U as it's written today uh
we appreciate what representative lad I
think is trying to do here but I don't
think the language before you uh does
that uh and so there are uh alternative
Pathways to uh to to becoming a
certified educator in a school um we've
talked a little bit about those uh when
this bill came before the education
committee last year um I think the
benefit of some of those Pathways as
well as you know the traditional route
of going through school is the support
that you receive uh the classroom
experience at the elementary middle high
school level which is very different
from a college setting and um you know
the community college system has a huge
range of students in terms of you know
their age and their experience uh it's
not the same as uh you know Middle
School um so um and with some of those
um Pathways there's if you're coming
from another profession there's a plan
in place how do you get the kind of
supports that you need the mentorship so
that you are um so that you're adapting
not only to the school U but to the to
to the climate in that school and of
course um as we've talked about before
uh you know there's there's uh the
pedagogy that you um learn uh that you
experience um and that um you know a
university system or Community College
faculty you know they may have a
talented uh writer that they bring in to
adjunct a class um and um but without
you know that sort of plan in place this
could be very
difficult uh today is a very difficult
time to teach even for experienced
teachers uh who are regularly going to
professional
development um and and
regularly uh uh you know de developing
in between the times that they seek um
their renewal for certif certification
for example exle
um so uh that professional development
we think is is very key uh that brings
up another point we have concern with
this bill unlike other uh Pathways like
say for example the one-year
certification this is not time limited
so there's no uh limit to as it's
written here as to being able to be in
the status of um part-time teacher so
that that brings up a couple of things
uh you know there's the issue around the
criminal records check and how often
that has to be done um on that
particular topic uh apologies for
jumping around a little bit but um I
think it does need to be checked on
Roman 2 about that the candidate is
Seeking a criminal res record check I
believe for uh the folks who are in a
school right now you have to have
completed that check not just so seek so
um just I I I would encourage you to
match up the language if if if I'm
mistaken on that uh if you decide to
move forward with this um and uh as well
as um so so in addition to the questions
around
um the time limit criminal records check
but also just what what is being done
for that person if they're going to
continue to stay work 20 hours a week
what is the support that they're going
to receive to make sure that they are uh
you know best able to serve um
students uh we talked about the last
bill
um about standards
qualifications um you know as I read it
in here there's nothing about any kind
of assessment testing for Content area
um and so and that whatever subject area
that person may be teaching as a
community college Adjunct professor that
I think this was raised earlier that
that's necessarily what they're coming
in to do at that school and so uh it the
bill seems to be silent on that I'm not
I don't think that was the intent but uh
to to leave that silent but I don't
think it's something that ought to be
left up to like the rul making process
for
example um so subject area
requirement uh that you've you know
shown that you know uh the content as
well
um the code of conduct piece I mean the
question uh I have about this is you
know one that we raised last year is how
does that work for an unlicensed
individual um and I think uh I haven't
heard that articulated how that how that
would work um and so that's an open
question that I'm posing here
um as as you work on this
bill uh and then finally just to close U
we are concerned that this will appear
as if the legislature is taking um a
step in trying to ease the educator
shortage but I don't think this is doing
that um you know the Band-Aids can often
be considered the solution when they are
only maybe exacerbating the issue of
what we ought to be focused on and I
think this was brought up earlier is
increasing Aid to local school districts
so that they can pay competitive wages
for their uh not only to compete with
other school districts you know Franklin
to Portsmith or you know but also uh as
representative lad
mentioned uh we have a lot of
alternative certifications uh being
issued people changing careers um and if
we're going to compete um that is going
to be critical and so for a community
that cannot you know struggles to raise
those funds to be able to to to do that
um I you know this is not uh solving
that problem so uh thank you for your
time I put two minutes I probably be
over that so appreciate that uh any
questions rtion of Hall thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question U Mr Hawkins in uh great to see
you here uh in your reading of this did
you see it as a concurrent dual enroll M
bills uh no I I um I mean I I appreciate
what I heard from repres represent L's
testimony that that is that that seems
to be the
intent the language just seems to be
lacking there and so thank
you and resent
Freeman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming in front of us today so from
your understanding what grades are the
Dual and concurrent enrollment uh
program addressing because I heard you
say something about middle school and
Elementary School what grades do you
understand that those programs address y
um thank you for the question and I
think that partly goes to uh
representative Hall's question as well
in that um uh dual and concurrent dual
and concurrent enrollment uh being the
high school level this doesn't specify
because it doesn't specify either the
grade levels or the Dual concurrent
enrollment program um it seems to allow
for you know any grade um at least as
it's written so thank
you yes representative um B
bony thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um if this bill
was reworked um for the more narrow
objective of dual concurrent enrollment
uh would you feel differently um and
what questions would you
have um so I think the questions we
would still have
is uh you know I mentioned the time
limits um some of the other uh Pathways
have a you know a renewal point or a a
point at which
um you know there's there's a
reassessment here so I think lacking
that I would be concerned
that um you know whoever the individual
is could just sort of stay in that
particular position and and through
notfall of you know I think the school
is pro is TR trying to do the right
thing they're trying to you know uh fill
positions and make sure their students
are getting the offering but you know
we're we're not doing a service to the
students either if we're if we're not um
you know paying attention to uh you know
how's that how's that educator doing are
they getting the supports that they need
and um you know that that time just like
if you were a certified educator you
have that period where uh of of of
non-renewal where where where if it's
not working and you're not someone who
ought to be in that profession the
school district has that option and um I
know that's a little different from what
we're talking about today but my point
in raising that is more about the the
ability to go and and sort of reassess
so thank you uh representative
Woodcock chair I actually one of the
question question is exactly what I had
is is um this young lady to my left
uh Mr H following up on on your
point if um and I I I think the intent
of the concurrent dual enrollment is is
terrific um honestly uh however if a a
part-time employee came uh to a school
system like this um but they still be
res and this may be in various school be
different I don't know but how would
they then be
evaluated um and would they be
responsive or required to do what other
faculty do in terms of faculty meetings
department meetings those things or are
they like an independent contract I
don't know if you've had any experience
with that I I don't so I don't know if
you have a if you may have a comment on
that
please yeah uh thank you for the
question um so I I think that's a little
bit of an open question I think it could
depend on a lot of things with respect
to you know the way the the particular
school is run um you know if they're uh
and as well as well as you know I there
was there there was a comment uh earlier
brought up about displacement so of of
uh existing positions and I go back to
sort of the the the Band-Aid question
about um you know
at a certain point if there's no time
limit here you're displacing um you know
full-time work and so
uh I I I bring that up also to your
question about you know would they be
subject to all these things I think it
depends I think it depends on uh the
school it depends on you know the
language of the bill depends on the rul
making um
so I know that might not answer your
question uh but uh I probably don't have
a great answer for you it it probably
depends on the school thank you thank
you thank chair yes thank you very much
for your
testimony um representative alone I'm
sorry representative Cel thank you so
much thank you for taking and thank you
for taking my question um you talked
about alternative routes to get
certified and so can you just give us a
couple of like two examples we'll keep
it really short of things that people
who are seeking alternative routes to uh
certification might get that are
essential to being successful at
teaching at the high school level that
someone coming in from a community
college might not know that they need
yeah I mean I think mentorship is a
great example I mean um there's a great
I can I'm happy to get this to the
committee but um there are uh we and
we've talked about mentorship in this
committee before there are um you know
teachers I know who know that a
particular school has a really great
mentorship program and that that made a
difference for them in terms of what
school that they were going to uh you
know work at and so or they changed jobs
because of that it wasn't just you know
salary so I I think mentorship maybe is
getting a little bit offline with the
bill um thank you very much um we have
two more people who would like to
testify thank you uh representative
alone
thank you Mr chair I'm Mark Malone I
represent the town of eeping I'm also an
educator 40 years uh plus or minus uh K
through 12 both as a teacher as
administrator at all
levels so I look at this bill and I
remember a a phrase one of
my uh colleagues used to say said we
hide in
ambiguity we hide in ambiguity
this is an ambiguous
Bill the way I read it and as a
principal looking for people I can hire
anybody for
anything as long as they have they come
through the university system or
Community
College pick the subject pick the level
I could have somebody come in and do 20
hours of uh tutoring and
reading can do it so my point is that if
and representative lad spent about 30%
of his conversation with you speaking
about dual
enrollment why isn't it in
here if it's that important put it
in but even
so based on
experience eping High School had a hard
time and still has a hard time getting
advanced placement teachers and getting
particularly in math and science I can
remember going through four biology
teachers in one year
as an administrator that was a
nightmare and then for advanced
placement math we finally we got a
brilliant brilliant PhD and math to come
in and teach advanced
placement he talked to his feet the
entire time and wrote on the board
there's no guarantee that there's going
to be a match between college level
professor and the needs of a
student no conversation about whether
these people can actually teach kids
and that's something that's right across
in education because the big assumption
is that anybody who has content
knowledge can teach and that's Croc
based on my
experience where's that where's that
protection in the
bill so the other thing I'll just say is
that
um we have to have we have to have good
people teaching kids who know how to
teach this bill does not address that
directly and if it if you want to put
the language in there please do and I
I'm particularly looking at ad looking
at full-time staff from the University
system I would feel better about but
adjunct faculty what are the
qualifications for being an adjunct
faculty member at a university or in the
the community college
system and again going back to what's
their ability to teach K through 12
kids I would put if you're going to
continue with this bill it really needs
some serious revision it needs time
limits because someone who has being
hired part-time year after year after
year they're not part-time
anymore and so the qualifications about
being able to teach kids should come to
the four on that so that's basically my
uh thank you very much
today thank you for your
testimony uh representative
house excuse me Deborah house
I'm not sure
either and for the first time I get to
say good morning chairman cardelli this
my first time testifying in front of
your committee I am very proud to be
here my name is debborah H I am the
president of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire we represent prek
through 12 uh Public School Educators
and staff as well as University faculty
public and private and uh Town employees
and I'm here in opposition to this bill
especially as it is written it does not
specify the Dual and concurrent
enrollment if that were in there it
might address some of our concerns about
how wide reaching it would be but we
would still have some
concerns um and I will try not to repeat
what has already been said but we do
have concerns about how this would
affect the student's experience in the
classroom as you know public schools are
different from community colleges and
universities Public Schools serve all of
the students in the district or at least
the ones whose families choose to send
them to public schools and those
students could have very different
learning needs um any child in a school
can take any class uh in high school
that they have meet the academ
prerequisites for so that means you
could have students in front of you who
have specialized learning needs who are
English language Learners who need uh
support with their learning based on
where they're at at learning the
language you could have uh accelerated
Learners you could have um students who
have behavior issues and you've got to
deal with them all as a teacher if you
are a University faculty or adun who
have come in you know to teach a class
as a part-time teacher you don't
necessarily have the background to
modify your lessons to meet all of those
needs in front of you if you're a
certified teacher you have learned about
that in your teacher preparation course
you have practiced it in your various
practicums in your student teaching and
you have been through some kind of
mentorship uh buddy teaching in your
first few years of teaching to help you
hone those skills so you know how to
deal with the students in front of you
so that you can keep them motivated and
on task as much as possible students go
don't get this learning time back if you
don't know how to do that so that's
really the main concern I have with this
from a student perspective if you get a
subject area expert who comes in who
doesn't know to H how to handle the
meeting students need part of teaching
then it's not going to help students
learn you could have you know a
brilliant math teacher as someone said
who talks to their toes it's not going
to help them um and I do also have to
take a uh I have to disagree with the
previous speaker who said that it's not
supplanting teachers it's already
happening if you can't hire teachers
because you can't pay enough or offer
them the benefits to fill those slots
and you're
already taking in community college or
university teachers to fill those
concurrent and dual enrollment classes
then you're already supplanting
uh existing teacher you're filling
existing positions with outside
part-time uncertified teachers so
otherwise there will be pressure to
raise the salaries the real answer is
for this legislature to do its
constitutional Duty by all of gr grite
State students and fully fund our Public
Schools so every single District can
offer the robust public education that
all of our students deserve and and uh
that's what I have to say thank you very
much you're welcome uh rent
Lichfield thank you chairman lad and
thank you for taking my
question my concern in listening to
having everybody come up here with their
testimony I'm still trying to understand
whether you're advocating for the staff
or the children right
now I'm advocating for both I want the
children who have a good experience in
the classroom and be able to learn but
all of them should be able to have that
opportunity not just a few so if a
student has some special needs the
teacher who is in front of them has to
be prepared to modify the lesson plan
and meet those those
needs that is part of the expectation in
a public school you're not just teaching
a few or teaching the middle or teaching
the best may I follow up quickly please
yes so if you are in one of these
courses I am assuming Maybe I'm Wrong
that you would be as a student in a
position I don't know how to put it
articulate this best but I would think
that you would the student would have to
be qualified to be in that class to
begin with and my concern is if I'm
hearing correctly that we have a
shortage unless a misunderstanding so if
we don't try to take this Avenue will
the children will be missing out
completely
we currently have a shortage
because we are
not offering
essentially wages that families can live
on in many communities so yeah you're
going to ask people to choose between
serving their community and keeping
their family housed and
fed people do not go into um don't take
a b property to go into education so um
that's why we have shortages in some
communities thank you very much y ument
Mong thank you chairman cordelli and
thank you along the same lines I have a
similar question I'm having a hard time
understanding this if there is a teacher
that is passes a background check and is
willing to work and and is qualified to
teach in that subject area wouldn't it
be better to have that teacher in the
classroom than no teacher at all and the
class wouldn't be offered and the
students wouldn't have the opportunity
to take dual and concurrent
enrollment so if you want to talk about
it as a temporary measure then make it
temporary make it lapsing after one year
while you work on actually fixing the
funding which has been ongoing for over
30 thank you very much represent C
quickly please thank you very much and
thank you for taking my question um you
brought up meeting the needs of special
needs children or children with learning
challenges yes um is there something
that makes it so that learning
challenged children would not be in dual
enrollment classes for any reason or
would a certified teacher who's been
through an education program know how to
um honor an IEP or 504 for their
students a certified teacher who has
been through an education program should
be able to meet the needs with some
assistance from a special education
teacher perhaps maybe there might be an
area where they would need a suggestion
or two to help them modify a lesson plan
we're not talking about accommodations
where you have to change the content of
what's uh in the syllabus but you're
modifying either your delivery or or um
a time element or or something um but
there is no reason that all special
education students should be excluded
from a dual enrollment or concurrent
enrollment course there's no reason an
English language learner should be
excluded categorically if they can meet
the academic prerequisites for getting
into the class they should be able to
take the class right I I think we're
getting a little off topic we just want
to make it clear in case I'm
sorry I'm not teaching here repres
Murray quickly please we're a little bit
behind thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to double check that I'm making sure
we're understanding that I I think to
one of the other members questions a
person can be twice exceptional and have
needs and meet the academic requirement
to be in that classroom yes but also
have needs that are required to be
successful in that environment yes and
we didn't even touch on behaviors
behavior management is a huge part of
teaching as well and that might be
something that a university Professor
hasn't encounter because students who
are paying tuition are more likely to um
be aware of focusing and and
um keeping up with what's going on in
class instead of acting out and and
disrupting others learning thank you
very much uh thank you for your
testimony uh Becky
[Music]
Wilson okay this chair sticks to the
floor good morning chairman cordelli and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Becky Wilson from the New Hampshire
school boards Association I just wanted
to uh clarify a couple of things that I
think we heard when we were listening to
the other testimony previously as well
as to just um I think ask some
clarification or questions that we still
had which is one is to clarify um in
regards to the issues with the special
education needs and the training of an
adjunct or Professor or employee of the
community system coming down to the high
school level um just a reminder that
idea and special education ends when the
child receives a high school diploma
most colleges and community colleges UNH
system Etc don't have to comply with
special education or idea that is done
when students go to college uh Section
504 is a bit different but there are
some adjunct professors or employees of
the college system that would never
potentially have had training and
special education so they really
wouldn't necessarily come with any of
that background um and under the way
this bill is currently written it's
unclear about what kinds of training
they would need to have um or
professional development coming down to
the high school level and sort of how
that would play out for a person who is
there to teach one or two AP classes at
the high school level um in addition we
have some questions assuming this person
would be an employee of the school
district even though they are part-time
it's our belief that the majority of
those people regardless of part-time or
full-time at the high school if it's
just for high school um would still fall
under collective bargaining agreements
and the requirements for part-time
employees or employees of the school
district they would still need to meet I
believe um any of the other like
mandatory trainings things like that
that any employees or volunteers of the
school district would need to be um held
accountable for uh so I think it would
just again when we're talking about
potentially offering some sort of clean
up language for this bill or an
amendment to consider sort of the
impacts of collective bargaining
agreements and on any employees of uh
local public school districts what are
the mandatory trainings and other things
that these people would be um falling
under that umbrella as well um I think
you know the way the bill was presented
by representative lad if it were really
to just be for dual and concurrent
enrollment um there are people
potentially who could just be teaching
one class at the high school level once
a day two hours but I think to be really
um clear about all the other pieces that
come with becoming a public school
employee regardless of how many hours
you work there or whether you're a
volunteer Etc I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony um I think that closes this
hearing um on uh
hb90 uh let me see if um representative
lad is available he is the Prime sponsor
of the next bill HB 235
okay we will um we will proceed and open
up the hearing for House Bill 235
relative to amending the educator code
of ethics and code of conduct to include
responsibility to parents and um uh
again representative vad thank you
thank you very much representative
cordelli and members of the committee I
apologize there's a lot going on in this
joint
uh
yeah pardon me the joint is jumping yeah
okay uh I'm here to introduce HB 351 I
know you're on a short rope here we you
know we've gone beyond our time this
bill is 235
235 this is Code of Ethics okay
okay uh 235 relative to amending the
Education Code of Ethics and code of
conduct to include responsibility to
parents
um this this uh statutory language was
put in place several years back when we
realized once in the state there was a
code of ethics and code of conduct but
there's no statutory language so they
repealed it and then we put it back in
place and I don't know if you all have
this book but uh it's one where uh that
was passed out to the committee last
year it's the code of ethics and the
code of conduct and within that it
specifies that in the code of ethics
which is aspirational in nature as I
mentioned in the preceding meeting the
code of conduct is action items that
lead to conduct and possibly
disciplinary
action the code of ethics in terms of
the aspir ational and in both areas have
four primary title areas which are part
of the code that we put into
statute a responsibility to the
education profession and educational
professionals so a teacher must be
professional towards people you're
working with and and your
profession B responsibility to students
obviously you're there for the primary
purpose of teaching students so you're
responsible to your
students C the third category
responsibility to your school community
so at large those people you're working
within the
community and D responsible and ethical
use of Technology as it relates to
students schools and other educational
professionals you know how you use that
how you interact on that web and all
that's part of that part right
there this legislation's been handed to
you because
nowhere in those four areas is the word
parent
mention I was looking through as I was
trying to clean up my file cabinets I'm
still one that uses a lot of paperwork
and and I had stuff dating back to 2008
and I say well that's no good going like
that this is going in circular file Etc
I did that and then I came on this this
older file right here the code of uh
ethics ethical
behavior and then it I had all that
stuff what what came from Connecticut
what came from Kentucky how we put this
together and I looked at one of the
areas which was the Preamble for the
Nea and in the Preamble it reads the
educator recognizes the magnitude of the
response possibility inherent in the
teaching
process the desire for respect and
confidence of one's colleagues so now
we're talking about the professionals
you working with your professionals your
Professional
Organization of students that's one we
also have in our code right here as one
of our primary uh
principles of
parents I look for that and that's
that's not in ours as a
primary one of the four principles and
of members of the community so it
mentions
community and initially when we had the
technology side I can remember the task
force saying maybe this ought to be
integrated in those other three and we
the legislature said no we're not going
there we want because where we're going
with AI where we're going with
everything else nowadays we need that as
a separate area of
responsibility because it's resulted in
a lot of a lot of happenings going on in
our schools today I believe and we'll
hear about that later when we start
talking about use of cell phones in
schools
but I looked at that and started
thinking maybe we need to get this word
parent into the that one of those four
areas so then I looked at this code
right here and I do have an amendment
I'm going to maybe I I to pass that out
for your consideration it would have to
be
introduced by somebody
within your committee Paul you want to
represent
Terry the initial language that you had
before you was modifying Item
B and it was saying responsibility to
student and
parent when I looked at this booklet
right here and took another look at it I
realized maybe we put parent into the
wrong principle maybe it belonged
elsewhere and when I'm speaking to right
now I will read to you because I know
you all don't have this handbook right
here in
the area where it says responsibility to
the student and when you look at those
principles underneath it
you're not going to see the word
parent and what the statute that we have
that's in this book right here we
through these four principles authorize
the State Board to develop rules in
support of those four categorical
areas so Ru making is is the result of
the rest of language within this little
handbook right
here so by putting the word parent in
that category B we're opening up the rul
making process
again but then I looked at principle
number
three and I said is that place that's
responsibility and commitment to the
schools but actually in in in law it
says responsibility to the school
Community to the school
community and underneath that principle
it communicates with parents and
Guardians in respectful manner which
represent students best interests
commits to equality equity and inclusion
of colleagues staff students parents or
Guardians and other members of the
school
Community respects diversity amongst
colleagues staff students parents or
Guardians and other members of the
school
community so underneath that principle
three parents are mentioned several
times so then the thinking is
perhaps what I've done is introduce the
bill and put the word parent in the
wrong
principle and so what I've offering you
right now is changing it from B to C and
saying responsibility to parents
Guardians and the
community therefore parents being up
there in that primary topical area are
supported by the language without having
to change that language internally
within this all we're doing is just
adding parent and guardian to category
C I know you're in a are hurry here so
I'm not going to Bel labor this any
farther that's what the intent of this
bill is to to get the word parents into
the code of ethics as a primary
responsibility area parents are involved
in your schools I know it was a big deal
in my community when we had parent
teacher conferences and we scheduled
those in the
schools and teachers looked forward to
that cu we could get 89 to 95%
attendance out of a school that had
approximately 500 kids we could do it
and we aimed to do it and parents and
our teachers knew that working
collaboratively with the parent is how
we're going to improve education that's
why we have things like PTA parent
teacher Association parent teacher clubs
parent teacher organizations pto's it's
important that we recognize and I think
by recognize in this code of ethics that
parents or
Guardians need to be there so that's it
and thank you very much representative
cordelli thank you uh questions
representative
Bon thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent L for taking my question um is
it your intent to just insert the
language then in the title of uh the
current code of ethics or is your intent
to um
um instigate a a review of the whole
booklet no by doing this well we we
should be we should be looking that
periodically
and back in I'm looking for the date
here February 9
2022 I was asked to write a letter to
the commissioner of education and we'
been discussing
this and you'll notice that in the code
of
conduct there are three ways
disciplinary action can be taken place
and the discussion we had had and we
huddled with the association we H
huddled with District our department
attorney in a separate room I think it
was the other half of this room and we
came up with language the first option
which we'd like to add in was
confidential letter of concern which
shall mean a non-disciplinary non-public
letter issued to the employee that would
be the first step so and and if there
was an issue with this it was handled
privately and with the individual
involved nothing was put in the record
then you get into other areas for
reprimand suspension and removal of your
ticket your license um I felt that it we
needed another step that was never done
I'm not aiming to have that done I'd
like to see it done but and this this
statute right this uh proposal this
legislation doesn't speak to rules at
all all is doing is speaking to trying
to change that one section of law which
you know I I mentioned those four
responsibility areas that's all we have
the rest of this stuff that takes care
is already in law where the State Board
is given the task of support of writing
the rest of that what we have on under
rulemaking those supportive principles
which support that topical
area he
followup so I'm I'm not really familiar
with how often this gets re reviewed or
renewed and it must follow the same
processes defined in the in the law um
but is it does it happen that
frequently when this whole thing was put
together was a task course of people put
together it was generated by the
legislature when I came down to the
state from up north um I was familiar
with having a code of ethics and
professional conduct and as were all the
other states we had had one but ours was
repealed simply because we had no
statutory language that backed up what
jel car had done and so we put in place
the language those four personal areas
there are giving rule making authority
to the State Board of Education whether
they have since modified these things to
best of my knowledge they haven't there
was a task force put together initially
to write what we have adopted in that
little book right now that was done by
teachers coming together working with
the department and um and that's that's
the result I don't believe this has been
modified since then um back in 2022
there was a suggestion written by myself
to the
commissioner as a request of the
education committee as a whole to
consider this fourth option in the code
of conduct side um I don't believe that
has
occurred because I I still operating out
of this and this has only three category
areas for reprimand suspension or or
removing your certification
certification representative
Murray okay representative Hall thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I just want to be clear this is
replacing principle
three yes uh it's uh I buried my
Amendment right here Amendment yes it's
it's doing C okay so I would just three
ask about if you look at principle two
uh responsibility commitment to the
student so the word commitment has been
removed on commment on
which I'm I'm sorry it's it's um am the
you're we're looking at it's amending
RSA
219 n as you can see in the
uh in the text of the
bill okay
okay we're we're amending RSA say 21 and
N right okay so all
right okay I was just looking okay so
it's not principal two and principal
three it's more so the RSA over here
it's not exact thank
you and may I in looking at what is in
statute and what they have there is a
little bit different in the book but
we're looking only as your chair said n
n 21 N9
n repr
Murray thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question so I do have a
one question Ru making Authority is
something that the department is then
granted pursuant to 219 n yes but uh 21
N1 is also enumerated um a policy of
finding statement so in the statute
there is already reference prior to rul
making to parents and students citizenry
Local Schools Etc so the ru making
Authority would operate under 21n as a
whole correct yes
okay thank you very much
representative I I see we have one
more uh card oh no more questions thank
you very much I get out of here um Brian
Hawkins
I'm
sorry uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee once again Brian
Hawkins representing NAA New Hampshire I
know we're Pas time so I'll try and keep
it brief um I have not seen the
amendment so I can't comment really to
the amendment I think um it just to
summarize I think our concerns
here uh lie with a lot of the feedback
we received is the the way uh the bill
is
phrased um Ed Educators see their
student their students as their primary
responsibility and uh there's a lot put
on we've talked about this committee
before there's a lot put on Educators
when it comes to all sorts of rules
regulations that you need to follow um
and they just want to go in there and
teach and educate and so I think the con
the feedback that I heard and I really
encourage you to look at the there were
quite a few people who signed in on the
bill uh and and did so with not just
checking opposition but you know many of
them U enumerated their concerns and and
and that was really the primary one
which was um at the end of the day uh uh
the respon their Prim Prim AR
responsibility is is to students um and
in the context of the code of conduct
specifically as to the professional
standard that they're held to that that
in that context is is is is critical uh
as representative lad said there is no
doubt that
uh the partnership with Educators and
parents engaged parents is critical in
you know getting to the best education
of our students so that's I'm not here
to Discount that at all um it's really
in the code in the context of um the
code of conduct which was when they when
it was formed looking back at some of
the records um last night it was um the
model policy that they essentially used
to to adopt the code of conduct there
was not a separate provision um about um
parent it was Community which as
representative lad said has inclusion
about uh you know professionalism to to
to parents um but you know when there
are issues at the school district level
um it's
the uh Administration principle th those
are some of the folks that are are are I
think there to facilitate when there if
there's an issue uh uh with you know how
a educator is
um you know responsible to a parent so
um I'll conclude my testimony there oh
I'm sorry one other uh key is I
think you also need to be really clear
on the intent because this does as it's
written does open up ruem and as we've
seen over a number of years there's a
lot of policym that tends to happen in
rule making when the legislature is not
clear about what it is they want so I
look forward to reviewing representative
lad's Amendment um and may send
something subsequent in uh to uh in
light of uh the change in language that
he's proposing so conclude there any
questions see none thank you very much
and happy to work with the committee if
you do a work session thank you thanks
so I will close the uh hearing on house
build
235 um we are scheduled for a 1:00
hearing on HB 286 um which we will start
at at 1:00 if you are a couple of
minutes late getting back from lunch
because you're going to some U nice
restaurant um we will uh understand as
this is just a hearing so en enjoy your
lunch
e
e e
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire I represent the
town of Epsom and uh first of all I want
to uh representative wer wants to
apologize for not being here today his
uh grandson is becoming a Green Beret
today and he's at the ceremony
so so that's why you got me you know
pinch heading here um
so I'm sure without taking a survey that
that the number one concern of your
constituents are the same as mine namely
property taxes and um not necessarily
because you know in some technical sense
those are the worst TX taxes but but
those are clearly the most obvious taxes
because everybody knows how much of
those taxes they pay I mean we all pay
bet BPT all the you know gas tax and so
on but you know nobody knows how much
they pay on those taxes but you since
you write a check twice a year in most
cases uh for property tax you absolutely
know how much you're paying and it's a
lot of money because I think the total
of all property taxes is uh greater than
the total of all other taxes that we
have right so it's it's our main major
tax um and and for the most part those
taxes go to schools and um so everybody
is concerned with the cost of schools
and that's why we have this other
committee you know the your committee
was bifurcated and I'm sit on the other
one uh dealing mostly with money and um
so one possible idea of of how we can
cut property tax and how we can save a
little bit of money would be
consolidation of
saus um we have over a 100 saus in the
state some of them are exceedingly tiny
when I whenever I talk to someone from
coas County they they never failed to
tell me that they have five saus in
their County even though the total
number of school kids in their county is
less than the city of Portsmouth for
example so so sius are quite can be
quite small they all have a
superintendent they all have an office
they all have so on so the idea is that
maybe by consolidating them into larger
saus you certainly would have fewer
superintendents but you could also maybe
get some economies of scale right you
know maybe if every one of a bunch of
small ones has a grant Rider maybe you
don't need you know if you consolidate
10 into one you don't necessarily you
need 10 gr grant writers you could maybe
get by with a few right that kind of
thing so um so we think there could be
some some benefits to consolidation and
as I I understand it you have you have a
couple of different choices of how to go
forward with this idea should you choose
to one is this bill which is a simple
committee to study it so the difference
between a committee and a commission is
a committee is is only uh elected
officials namely representative and
Senators um a commission has also
outside people so you you're the next
bill you're going to hear is from
representative lad same sort of idea
with a lot more detail but it's a
commission so it has many many others
that are from outside the um other
organizations and so on and you will
also at some point be getting my bill
House Bill
765 where I actually wrote the law to do
this thing right to to consolidate saus
so if you want to sort of skip the
committee and study stage and go
straight to the action that's what my
bill is for so so you have a lot of
choices coming up and I would just my
recommendation to you would be at least
um not exec any one of these bills until
you've heard them you've had the public
hearing for all for all of them and then
think about you know which direction do
you want to go if you if you choose to
on on any of them and I'm happy to
answer
questions uh thank you very much for
pens
shating represent Woodcock thank you
thank you Mr chairman great afternoon
good to see you um is there anything now
that precludes a series or multiple seus
and doing this on their own I mean the
three of us are three different seus is
I I haven't seen it precludes us from
getting together and say you know what
maybe our town should do this yes thank
you for the question representative so
um saus are controlled by RSA
194c and I believe there is a procedure
in there that was just adopt came in
last term that how for saus to
consolidate if if they wish to I think
that my own personal opinion is there's
probably uh the incentive is not
necessarily there for the people
involved to do this right because
certainly if if there's efficiencies
people will be losing their jobs and and
so I think there'd be a lot of
resistance where so that's why sometimes
we have to put Force the the issue
rather than have it happen sort of
naturally follow there is process
absolutely yes that was just passed last
time so I I doubt it's been used yet
right so yeah represent s
thank you so much and thank you for
taking my question um I'm just curious
how a bill like this is going to impact
districts that send their students
across state lines we we know we have
kids who are at schools in Partnerships
with schools in Vermont and in Maine um
I don't believe there's any going South
of the Border but um I I just don't know
how something like this is going to
incorporate that yes thank you for the
question representative um yes there are
of the 104 saus there are two cross
school districts one with Vermont one
with Maine and in those cases the SAU
and the school district are one and the
same right they're they're
um is their they um single school
district saus and um I had to deal with
that in my legislation and my I simply
chose to not touch them so they would
stay in exactly as they are they're not
they wouldn't be
Consolidated like the others would
but it is some this is all again this is
a committee that this particular bill is
a committee that would study the issue
so what the study comes up with is up to
them it's just I had to deal with that
in my bill and that's what I chose to
do represent Murray okay yeah that's
right yeah thank you uh any further
questions seen none thank you very much
representative
uh Jerry
Hugh good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Jerry Fu and
I am the associate executive director of
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association organiz ation of
superintendents assistant
superintendents curriculum directors
business officials student service
officials and uh technology
directors we also have several of the
charter school heads as part of our
association when I heard chairman
cordelli yesterday state that there was
an intentional effort uh to contain the
number of committees and commissions
established by this legislature I said
this is music to my ears perhaps we can
help chairman cordelli achieve achieve
that
goal with all due respect to the bill
sponsors and we appreciate the notion of
cutting property taxes and containing
local expenses in school districts um
I'm here to tell you that probably
superintendent salaries aren't the main
drain on that um on that property tax
effort but uh I digress on that
statement when I first uh saw the
proposal it I did find it curious that
one of the Bill's sponsors represents a
5 town school administrative unit who
has two
superintendents uh whose citizens have
determined that that's the appropriate
model for what their five communities
desire and uh determine the need for uh
in their local area and I think that
would be the case in most um in most
areas the model of a county
superintendent may work in some areas of
our country but if you lift up the hood
and Peak underneath you're probably
going to find layers of Bureau
Ry and um quite honestly not a lot of
savings uh and a lot of confusion and a
lack of connection to local communities
and so we don't feel that that's what
Grand estaters want uh out of their
superintendant so what does a
superintendent do
anyway the value of a skilled and
knowledgeable education a leader in a
school system cannot be
overstated they're only the ultimate
they are not only the ultimate guardians
of taxpayer resources they're the
Champions for Children Educators and the
educational communities that they serve
in my 50 years of work in public
education including tenur at the middle
school high school and systems
leadership level I've had the
opportunity to observe and experience
educational leadership in a variety of
roles I've also had the honor and
privilege to serve as an educational
leader as a superintendent of
schools most people agree when they
think about it the public education is a
public good an overall an essential
value that promotes a positive and
thriving Community a healthy and
evolving economy and a vibrant and
well-informed
democracy these facts are validated
validated in independent studies by
Business Leaders sociologists education
researchers and even political
candidates there's no mistaking the
important role of public education in
our society it is essential and
integral but what do school leaders have
to do with this public good
anyway I would submit a
lot the role of the education leader in
today's everchanging world can be best
described as the CEO of one of the
largest employers and service agencies
in our economy and certainly one of the
largest and most complex organizations
in a local community in another way this
leadership role can be practically
compared to the oldtime juggler on The
Ed Sullivan Show I apologize to those in
the rooms whose reference that is very
vague for representative I I'm looking
at
you but
that person who was able to spend
multiple plates on separate sticks
simultaneously for an educational leader
these plates include but are not limited
to Student Learning student and District
budgets and finance Schoolboard and
committee planning legislative tracking
and response plans you know those big
red books that you many of you have got
sitting in front of you uh it's the job
of the education leader to make sure
that gets taken care of at the local
District communication community
relations maintenance and capital
Improvement Personnel Transportation
professional development licensing
credentialing policy development
technology leadership leadership growth
and development student staff
safety specialized student services and
in most recent times since the pandemic
the additional plates of masking remote
learning book bands and culture Awards
have all added heat to all of those
plates that we're supposed to juggle in
that I mention snow day and weather
related
decisions as an example of the nature of
Demands on a
superintendent in a 4-day stretch
earlier this year in one of our state's
regions along with the typical duties
and responsibilities superintendents
were dealing with transgender right
protests the threat of a data breach a
dysfunctional boiler a tragic death of a
student and life-threatening injuries to
two others in an automobile accident a
teacher passing away in the hallway of a
school just prior to the start of a
school day and in one of these same
districts they had just dealt with the
Unexpected death of a recent
graduate these all were where the in the
same county in just a few short days how
would one superintendent be expected to
deal effectively with all these major
issues in several school districts and
communities
simultaneously in New Hampshire this
juggling is done at the sa office
level which provides professional
educational leadership to a school
system or systems to provide context the
specialized leadership work can be
grouped into major areas of
responsibility that have been described
above the following list specifies a
little bit more about the areas of
responsibility and activities in general
leadership maintain an absolute focus on
student learning and success act as a
CEO for the strategy Vision collaborator
consensus building evaluator policy
advisor spokesperson and more the
hearing officer and appeals judge for
all disputes by students employees and
citizens a legal uh representative for
the school district manage school boards
relations Associated committee work and
task forces and other leadership work
for example the superintendent in Conway
may have to deal with five or six boards
the superintendent in sa6 may have eight
or nine boards that they're dealing with
along with regional work and even in a
place like conquer where there's only
one school board I checked that
superintendent schedule this morning
there are 10 night meetings for that
superintendent for various committees
and task forces in the month of January
alone that's just night meetings with
the school board that has nothing to do
with attending some of the athletic
events the concerts the curriculum fairs
and all by the way that school board has
decided that they need a Saturday
Retreat on a Saturday in January so
that's part of the work I have a list of
the New Hampshire education department
reports that um superintendents are
responsible for ifying and uh certifying
but there's only 10 minutes left in this
hearing so I'm not going to read that
list of reports because frankly that
could take up a majority of the 10
minutes thank you but I'm not done sorry
there's more stuff curriculum
instruction leading the research and
development the what and how how schools
work staying current with best education
and assessment practices
designing professional development for
those teachers that you hear about so
often in the in the work they need to do
personnel management collective
bargaining agreements at times it's not
unusual for for a superintendent to be
involved in five six seven collective
bargaining negotiations in a small
several month period to sit at the table
to represent the citizens to protect the
teachers and to try to come up with
collective bargaining agreements that
serve the needs of the taxpayers as well
as the employees um Finance I don't need
to talk about the the financial
responsibility that um that they have
developing maintaining purchasing and
control
uh pieces area agreements tuition
agreements uh those things that once
again serve the needs of kids but also
protect um and service protection to the
local community student services
probably the fastest growing and most
complex area assuring special education
and 504 Services following and complying
with all treny and attendance
requirements track Contracting with
special education service providers and
you've heard about the the challenges of
finding Staffing so you still have to
provide those Services somehow you've
got to search the best contracts you've
got to try
to try to balance the needs of kids and
the ability of the community to support
the needs of those kids uring the needs
of court plac and Foster home students
are addressed ensuring students and
employee physical and emotional safety
needs are met ensuring access to a free
and appropriate education for English
language Learners and then there's
Communications and community relations
to effectively tell the story of the
district to attract develop and retain
the best teachers to provide
accountability answer the questions
respond to those right to no request
have effective relations with local
public charter schools advise the board
on facilities use and and what's
happening with the investment of the
community to provide an annual report on
the actions of all of the schools and
what how the school district is
functioning for its taxpayers and they
should and oh
yeah that I mention snow days and
weather related
decisions maintenance and capital
Improvement you all know your school
buildings and your communities are among
the the greatest capital investment um
in your communities often times it's the
responsibility of the superintendent to
make sure that those resour those assets
are protected that safety precautions
are taking place that a HVAC systems are
working um and all it takes is listening
to a couple of recent uh school board
meetings in the city of conquer about
what happened to the condition of the
Middle School to understand how people
feel about
um conditions that deteriorate over time
due to lack of investment and a
community
like the juggler an education leader
never has the satisfaction of spinning
just one plate before stopping to begin
another rather the work of an SAU leader
involves con constantly balancing these
comp competing responsibilities these
services are not always visible to the
public and sometimes go unnoticed
especially if they're done well in the
past Finance was regarded as the most
critical of responsibility however the
Advent of new laws regulations
expectations generated by the public and
Regulatory Agencies have caused an
increase of exposure risk financial and
otherwise for the school organization
the employers the students and the
community in general research tells us a
whole lot
about strong statistically significant
relationship has a positive correlation
when there's stable District uh
leadership that and that will impact
student
achievement in closing School District
administrators provide an essential and
costeffective benefit for not only
Educators staff and schools but also for
the taxpayers and most importantly
children School superintendents are part
of the fabric of their communities it's
simply not feasible for 10 of them to
provide proactive collaborative
effective timely responsive personal
student and Community centered
leadership to over 400 communities in
our
state oh is it I
mention snow days and weather related
events thank you for the opportunity to
speak I appreciate your time thank you
questions representative Freeman thank
you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony does this bill threaten to
eliminate
superintendant thank you for the
question representative this does not
threaten to represent superintendant I
believe what it threatens is local
control I I I I asked you this is a
study committee to see if this is
feasible so again I'll ask you a
question does this bill say that we want
to get rid of superintendent it does not
thank
you R SEL thank you so much and thank
you for taking my question um I I was a
teacher in Maryland which is countywide
school districts where we had a
superintendent with I think it was 12
sub assistant superintendents to cover
all the different areas because there
was an assistant superintendent of
English and math and at secondary level
Etc as well as various Elementary and
special education so is there any
evidence that doing consolidation of
superintendent work would in fact save
money rather than costing more thank you
for the question representative I think
you just described what looking under
the hood looks
like I'm not quite sure that any money
would be saved by any District because
the jobs still have to be done I don't
care if you're Salem Franklin pum B
wherever those jobs have to be done and
they have to be done with with a touch
to the local community I think that's
what's different like our members are
part of their communities they're part
of the rotary they're part of the of
just a presence like frankly my personal
experience one of the greatest
satisfactions I had as a superintendent
is going to a Friday night football game
that's awesome you get to see the people
you get to you're approaching to the
people in your community that's the
touch that's what New Hampshire wants
they want to know who their
superintendent is the superintendents
want to know who their employees are who
their children
are further questions see none thank you
very much thank you Mr
F uh ER Christina
thank you chairman cordelli good
afternoon members of the committee bar
Christina from the New Hampshire school
boards Association to be clear we're not
taking a position on this bill um if if
if if the legislature wants to study
something have added and hsba is always
available to provide whatever guidance
expertise experience and research that
we're able to provide I just want to
give a little bit of of background about
um sort of the the rise of the number of
of school administrative units I'll say
the last 20 years dating myself um I've
been with n hsba about 20 years now when
I started nsba in 2005 there were there
were 84 I believe school administrative
units were up to
107 um and in my experience um you know
in speaking with the school boards that
were going through the
withdrawals um uh going through the
withdrawal process um a lot of the
things that Mr fuit just spoke about is
why a community wanted to be on their
own and wanted to have their own SAU
they wanted their own Central office and
they wanted their own superintendent and
they it may have cost them a little bit
of money but that District the people in
that District the voters in that
District decided you know what it may
cost us a little bit more money but
we're having our own person now we're
having our own superintendent rather
than having to share that superintendent
among two three four seven or eight
school districts um so you know it's not
my job to tell the people in cuden that
they can't have their own superintendent
it's not an HSB job to tell the people
in Timberlane that they can't have their
own superintendent straford Rollinsford
is currently purchasing services from s
from summersworth they used to be in SAU
56 together Rollinsford withdrew from
that SAU I want to say maybe 10 years
ago and simply turned around and
repurchased
services from from uh from from
summersworth over the course of 10 years
uh Rollinsford currently has an
advertisement out they're advertising
for their own part-time superintendent
because they've decided that we want our
own person that we hire we evaluate and
we dictate their employment and they're
our person then and we can have the
school board can manage that individual
and and adopt the policies and tell the
people and the board can tell the
superintendent of Rollinsford what they
want for the Rollinsford School District
um again so you know it it it's not
always the withdrawals were not always
about saving money sometimes it was
about um having your own person um you
know that that that is that is dedicated
to your school district and the people
in your community um representative
Maguire did mention um that there was a
bill that passed last session about an
incentive and to incentivize
consolidation of of of saus I forget the
bill number um but basically the
consolidation has to occur I believe uh
the year 2030 was the deadline so
there's about four or five years for
saus to consider this and I believe it
was an extra $200 um per student um on
your on uh on your adequa a that you get
your state grants obviously that's that
bill is only maybe not even 6 months old
depending on when the effective date was
but um we haven't we haven't you know
obviously I I haven't heard of any
districts or any saus considering that
maybe they will in in in future years I
would also be remiss though without um
identifying um sort of AJ the position
between the two three four bills that we
have the session about consolidation of
school administrative units while
comparing and contrasting that with the
number of bills that we've had uh in
this room the last couple of years
seeking to make it easier for
Cooperative school districts to break up
sort of you know not consolidating and
not perhaps saving costs but letting
school districts go out on their own um
and yes as the law currently States if a
district withdraws if a pre-existing
District withdraws from a Cooperative
School District they still remain in the
existing school administrative unit the
same SAU however there is a provision in
the law that says the withdrawal from
the
co-op and the withdraw from the SAU can
occur concurrently and my best guess was
that if we see it easier to break up
with the co-ops to break up at some
point those little districts the little
K through 5 elementary school or the k
through eight elementary school they're
going to want their own superintendent
for the same reasons that cin and
timberlan and Nottingham and Hill and
Goan and Wakefield and Cornish and Cen
and and and all the other districts that
have created their own saus over over
the last 10 years have have have have
have chosen to withdraw so um again
we're not taking a position on the bill
if the if the legislature wants to study
this and hsba is happy to provide
information guidance resources but um
you know if if if I don't know where all
the new people are from on the committee
I I should I should probably print
myself off a little cheat sheet so so I
do know but if any of you are in those
communities that I that I've listed off
in the last couple of minutes talk to
your constituents talk to your school
boards about why did we withdraw from
whatever SAU we were we were we were
previously with it's because they wanted
those more personalized Services even if
it may have cost a little bit more money
so with that I'm I'm happy to answer
happy to answer any any questions
representative D thank you and thank you
for taking my question I just I want to
know are you aware that some places
inherited their they use when other
people dropped out and exact my town of
planfield left holding the bag when
Claremont and I mean know Grandam and
Lebanon left so it wasn't a decision of
Our Own It
was it just happened that way yeah yeah
thank you thank you for the question
that that's a that's a good point um
planfield may not have wanted to
withdraw from you may have been
planfield may have been happy with the
arrangement that you had I guess one of
the challenges is that and and you know
we've talked about the Cooper withdrawal
process and how some individuals and
representatives might think that that's
burdensome or unfair to the smaller
School District the SAU withdrawal
process is very very easy you do a study
commission the study commission come
commission committee a local study
committee the study committee comes up
with a recommendation and then only that
Community votes to withdraw so I I
forget what other communities were
previously with Playfield but you but um
you know the Cornish was one issue one
gr and leanon gram okay so when Grantham
wanted to withdraw it was only the
people in Grantham voting to withdraw
from that SAU and when Lebanon wanted to
withdraw it was only the the voters so
the SAU withdrawal process is very very
easy if that Community wants to withdraw
from the SAU they withdraw and planfield
has no say in that so this may be
getting a little bit cart before the
horse but you know a recommendation
might be to if there was a study
commission um you know tightening up the
the process for withdrawal um maybe a
moratorium on sa withdrawals we've seen
moratoriums with building Aid previously
um the State Board put a moratorium on
appr proving Charter Schools maybe 15 or
so years ago um when the state basically
did not have any money for to approve
new charter schools so again that's sort
of getting cart before the horse but
there there may be some ideas but you
know the one Super One superintendent
per county is you know you can see where
my predilections would be but um anyway
thank you for the question
representative
yeah R
fre thank you Mr chair and it's so nice
to see you again you as well two
Representatives you have n have known
each other for a few years um I do have
a question for you you do know that I
was on the Manchester School Board um
and I i' I've heard some scenarios
worked up about how the superintendent
has a long list of items well one of the
things that I've observed and you have
as well working with the Manchester
school district is the number of support
staff that are in the superintendent's
office do you have any idea how many
positions are in just the Manchester
School District as far as support for
the superintendent thank you for the
question I I don't know the Staffing in
in Manchester I imagine it's quite
significant though well I I I actually
counted it I just a rough guesstimate
it's about 30 positions in um in the sa
office to support the superintendent and
if I may follow up thank you um and do
you know of how many open superintendent
positions we have in the state right now
I I anecdotally I think there're about
seven or eight don't quote me on that
though in any given year 10 is about
average I'd say we've had some years
where there have been as few as five or
six and again anecdotally we've had
years there was a year I forget I think
it was preco we had one year there were
like 20 25 openings across the state
typical I'd say would be about 10 per
year right and we know how difficult it
is to find superintendent it can be yes
yes it can be so I want to thank thank
you um for answering my questions thank
you anything further seeing nothing
thank you very much thank you very much
U with that I'll close the hearing on
this bill and next up is HB 292 and uh
I'll see if I find once again our Prime
sponsor
going up and down
we will now open up the uh hearing on
House Bill 292 establishing a commission
to study school administrative unit
consolidation and welcome back uh
representative
lad thank you very much representative
Cordell for the record my name is Rick
lad I come from hail New
Hampshire and uh I'm here today to
introduce HB 292 which is a bill that
establishes a commission to study the
issue of consolidating
saus on the way back down the hallway
I've heard some of the discussion on the
previous bill so I'll try not to
replicate what had been said there um
I'm looking to
uh at this whole issue a a little bit
differently than those where we're
saying we're going to go right out and
consolidate into one per per per County
I can tell you right now in gron county
that won't work Littleton and hail will
not agree to what's going on in Lebanon
and
Hanover and Lebanon and Hanover control
the vote uh so uh it would just create a
firestorm up in my rule neck of the
woods but there are some things which we
need to look at in terms of the
consolidation of these 107 saus which we
have and it's something we can't negate
or not do we need to take this healthy
look at looking at what are the costs
are there any efficiencies which we can
gu gain out of this um we do know that
there are only two other locations in
this country that hire have higher
administrative costs not principal ships
administrative costs than this State per
per per
capita and that is Missouri and it's not
a state Washington
DC and
so maybe there's something we can do to
look at this as you recall on the
committee last year we had a bill HB
1450 and maybe it's the year before but
it all runs together that was the bill
which we initially had is the
consolidation of the two systems
community college system and University
system of New Hampshire
we had a very effective study shared by
uh uh Mr
applebe which looked at this with
Representatives on it Senators on it and
other people coming in from other angles
so it was a
commission and we recognized that
consolidation to the one system with all
the governance issues with all the
negotiated agreement agree issues with
the mission statements the culture of
higher education in the state needing
seven community colleges which are
independent from the University system
but also link though in many ways plat
it we need to communicate with it
transferability of credit we need to do
that we need to look at things to be
more affordable more accessible to our
students and so the issue of
consolidation of
saus maybe there's some things we can
look at and and maybe some things we can
learn
um going down here um the literature I
read is that you don't go through a
process like this just because things
are higher costing right now for example
we we see some tremendous jumps in cost
of doing education in the state in 2000
to
2023 our enrollment declined by
23% a
quarter and
our cost per pupil jumped by
81.6% other words we jump from
$1,192 per pupil to over $20,000 323 in
2023 so we jump from 11 to 23 uh 20
$20,000 that's a huge jump and we know
that I don't think there's many people
here in communities where you're not
shouting about assessed property values
and yes our state relies upon that as
one of our Revenue
sources uh for Education there's a
number of them that that's not what this
committee is about so let's look for a
second some of the possible outcomes
that could come from uh shared services
Maybe by districts coming together saus
I'm talking about I'm not talking about
the Local District the
seus we might be able to improve
transportation services
Information Technology security special
education services some districts don't
have that service the way the
neighboring service may have it so is
there a way of sharing that I know that
uh Speech Pathology services in the town
of Warren which is one of my towns is
coming by way of online services from
California because we cannot afford the
cost of a speech therapist or they're
not available for a small school that's
students Legal Services could be shared
Food Services could be shared uh
curriculum development and Prof
professional development time well
wouldn't be wonderful if there's
something going in District a over here
and District B over here and you're in
District B but you love to gain
information about what's going on in
District a so you could share that
development for for staff we could
better coordinate some of our curricular
areas like mathematics which we need to
work on in the state now we're trying to
do that through math learning
communities but this is one area where
we could do in K through 12 and and uh
so Human Resources I won't go on anymore
but there's a lot more things that could
be
outcomes there are some issues which are
going to hamper going into uh uh uh one
large SAU like Hawaii or or going into
ones by counties which have been
proposed
I see one of the biggest issues besides
negotiated agreements and contracts and
all that which you've heard about
already is culture culture Within These
communities when you talk about the
little town of permont in my community
which is a
district coming to hail for elementary
school they're saying wow we're going to
lose our community center we're going to
lose the school which houses our 68 kids
that are k through eight we're going to
lose our K through 8 program but then
the other side of side saying
saying but your eighth grade and 7eventh
grade only have three or four or five
kids in each of those levels what kind
of social experience are they getting
are they getting what holl middle school
can
provide but we don't want to lose our
school um it goes on and on um so I I I
guess what I would like to say by doing
what I'm proposing here that we have a
commission
study there's some validity to doing
this the study we had in 1450 which
started out as a consolidation study it
came up how we going to align some of
those horrendous issues that we're
dealing with on the university community
college levels and now we have quarterly
reports coming back to us from the
chancellors of both schools in fact
we'll have another one here in another
three weeks or
so how can we improve well we came out
with the task force of a number of short
term initiatives and long-term
initiatives to enhance higher education
one of them Dr Don Burks is already
imposed at at Plymouth State going to a
three-year bachelor degree for six
different subject areas which is a great
idea because that is an affordability
issue and it's also one that gets people
out into these career areas through a
pathway that's as quicker you know you
know I of course I never really was a
lover of reading Shakespeare but you
know shakes exp is necessary to have in
the Collegiate level you need to have
that experience available to all the
students who want to have that type of
experience but it's not necessary if
you're going to go off and become a
mechanical
engineer uh you need to learn some of
those other things so getting back to
where we are right
here in the year 2023 there were a
number of states that took the
initiative to have some kind of a uh
consolidation study done they went from
Arkansas to Illinois to Massachusetts to
Michigan North Carolina New Hampshire
and in New Hampshire here we had HB 1579
as you may recall and representative
cordelli was involved with that
pre-existing saus May merge
administrative office offices to include
Personnel merger grants were awarded for
those that would would decide to go that
uh Direction up to $200 per pupil for
the first two years so gave some kind of
a carrot or some kind of assistance to
help move in that
direction I don't know I don't think
anybody's grabbed a hold of that uh but
that was a concept that was out there
available uh Oregon Pennsylvania South
Carolina Tennessee Vermont Washington
Wisconsin and Wisconsin all all got
involved with in 2024 Kentucky New
Jersey and West Virginia went down that
road I want to take a moment and speak
to what happened in
Vermont cuz I get up in the morning I
look across my deck Across The Meadows
below me and I look right in the v ront
and representative Dr you probably do a
very similar thing down where you're
living Vermont acts 153 156 and
notorious act
46 uh they also had a bill HB
385 that was a bill that was in their
house which attempted to move toward a
single Statewide School District similar
to Hawaii it's
fail the other act 46 has not resulted
in a corresponding decrease decrease in
pure per pupil spending in districts
that have Consolidated or emerged but it
has linked into communities K through 12
opportunities many of these smaller
districts were
k8s and they were small but they in
talking if we were to talk to some of
the people that were superintendents
over there or school board members and
IAB one of those individuals was
superintendent of
sau23 went over and took care of Orange
County he came back said Rick it's
costing us a lot of money there were
some real positive things that came out
of it though and I would like to just
highlight some of those things where a
commission could net us some
gains Cooperative purchasing
agreements that's one of the things
that's come out of the community college
system in University system why should
we be purchasing things separately not
using the same technology can we do that
on a wider scope not for just SAU one
two or three but for you know getting
together and doing it in a larger scope
I think there is an efficiency there
there's a gain um combine Financial
Services budget
management there are some districts
which are very very small and if you
look at the research and I took some
time to do the research on this one
there are smaller districts perhaps AB
budding each other which would
gain by moving together similar cultures
right beside each other different things
offered in these school districts but
you combined it you might be able to get
some shared
resources and you and have a singular
budget director manager that's a
game um when you have a school district
the size of some of our small ones C
Pont under 100
kids um that is expensive and it's also
hard for them to find the Personnel to
work in their
schools Warren had to go chase down a
speech pathologist in California and do
it online that doesn't heck help a kid
that's in K12 trying to learn how to say
R you know or articulation issues and I
often times say they do that anyways in
Massachusetts so what's wrong with it uh
enhanced roles and opportunity for
shared Educational Services in districts
and when you do that across lines you
can you can save Ser uh share those
Services especially in special
education um you could have shared
curriculum perhaps and and that's what
we're trying to sort of do like when we
get the curriculum learning program
going communities we bring them to
everybody together but we're trying to
get a similar program going so we have
the same benchmarks and we have the same
expectations meeting the same standards
but we also have the flexibility within
to reach out to those students have
different learning styles than others
and there's different teaching styles
that have to pair all those learning
styles um professional development can
be a winner um now in looking at when we
did the cons uh um the
consolidation
um oh now let me talk about this one
here knowledge communicated to all
within a large District from saus Office
often times is more effective when I
chaired the commission on public school
infrastructure that's Homeland Security
where Security Access
Communications all that money available
up to $100,000 per school when we
reached out to the smaller districts
some of those small districts didn't
even know there was such a grant out
there now why don't they know is it
because they're superintendent maybe
it's on a contractual basis there may
maybe every other week um because you
they have a superintendent contracted
superintendent with a larger one next
door um can't afford to have a full-time
superintendent and doesn't make much
sense if you're just a school of 100
kids but those schools have security
issues also they need that
information and uh that's just one
example right there Creer technical
education we last year allocated four
million two years ago in our B in budget
$2 million per year
uh grant money for transportation above
and beyond the $9 million which we
allocate annually again I asked CTE
directors and uh represent Cornell
you're familiar with this process that
how many people out there in the weeds
the rural areas urban areas actually
knew about this money is
available if you're
beyond and and up to several weeks ago
out of that 4 million we only spent
about
2.5 some are not accessing these things
because the knowledge hasn't been
imparted with a larger operation going
on it's possible that that communication
could be disseminated by the
superintendent through the staff working
and get out rather than having to rely
upon these small districts where a lot
of that support's not available they're
meeting the legislative law the statute
but are they getting the service that
they really need uh
so lastly in looking at this
commission I have no loyalty to the
makeup of the commission at all I would
like to see if there's going to be a
commission study at all that we put
people on it that are really
knowledgeable of what the structure and
organization of the state looks like and
there is there any areas where we could
consolidate maybe those smaller
districts we got to do something we
cannot continue to be paying out on
average just for the superintendent
alone somewhere between $150
$160,000 local districts are not going
to be able to continue doing
that and so is there any way we can
consolidate in some areas I'm not
advocating that we have one per County I
I just think that is we have too many
school districts that cross
lines um and there there there are so
many issues so looking at the makeup of
that commission if you see folks which
could be an asset if you want to go
forward with some kind of study we've
had studies before we've had studies in
the community college system and the
university system before this one worked
we are getting reports back and we're
seeing what we have to do to get these
efficiencies to scale in place I do
believe we need efficiencies to scale we
do need to look at the organization
structure in this state
and yes um uh Mr Barrett Christina is
correct we did uh allow one District to
split up this last year but there was a
lot of real reasons for that and some of
them were very very solid reasons but
that's not the answer in our school
building Aid what have we done one of
the conditions for getting School B
building Aid is
consolidation we're going to have to our
demographics don't allow us to continue
funding everything we're doing we got to
really take the initiative and just
because it may have failed some places
some places it's working a little bit a
little bit's good for us
even so that's why I'm advocating a
commission rather than the other thank
you very much Mr chair and take any
questions thank you any questions for
representative
lad seeing none thank you very much
thank you very much uh next up is Doris
oy
good
afternoon chairman cordelli members of
the committee I'm Dar heny a former
School Board member from NASA I think a
review of the superintendent duties will
be useful there's 21 that I found in RSA
194 F4 the New Hampshire District system
was created in 1805 for the purpose of
raising money to build schools and give
residents a right to vote in District
affairs that was local control parents
were able to squit school districts by
notifying the town clerk on the
education portion of their property
taxes was Reed to their new District
that was public school choice these
grammar schools taught Reading Writing
and arithmetic families provided the
textbooks except for the poor they were
provided by the town these were free
schools in addition to private schools
andies the state then decided to create
saus by offering a little extra money to
consolidate at the time there over over
3,000 school districts and the state
decided that consolidation would save
money so here we go again reducing the
number of superintendent centralizes
control on even a larger number of
districts can make it more difficult for
parents to have a genuine voice in the
education of their children this is
especially important when parents
disagree with the superintendent and
trust me disagreements happen the loss
of local control Abate aggravates
parents saving money isn't the only
consideration if it's truly C savings a
detailed accounting of all federal funds
and mandates will be extremely helpful
even school board members don't get
complete information on this topic
superintendents are required to oversee
compliance with state and federal
mandates so dig down some mandates are
timec consuming invasive of privacy
others just ineffective towards student
outcomes it might not be coste effective
to accept funding in exchange for
implementing certain mandates if you
review the tasks of the superintendent
please review each task in New Hampshire
we spend 4 billion 8.4% comes from
federal aid that's roughly 3 336 million
for this our public schools are busting
budgets raising property taxes
implementing costly Federal mandates and
hiring endless
administrators even if we're
entertaining the now we're entertaining
you the efas to bailout students from
public schools that are considered
unsuitable or unsafe so we're going in
two directions there's considerable
savings to be had if we eliminate
Federal compliance systems we might not
need so many efas restore local control
and get the federal monkey off our backs
under the membership section of this
bill there are two members from the New
Hampshire school boards Association I'd
ask that you give a add two members from
the school district's governance
Association this is another very active
Statewide group for school board members
and I thank you for your time
[Music]
Marie
Banfield such a strange
chair it is um Amry Banfield uh I've
been parental rights advocate in New
Hampshire on be and focused on
excellence and education for probably
about 20 years I think uh represent
sentive lad you're probably the only one
in this room that's been around longer
than I have um I do support this because
it's going to study the situation uh
there's some things that representative
lad brought up I'm not sure I would want
it for my school uh this curriculum
sharing I I do like the idea of you know
each School making sure that but as long
as it's you know um voluntary so be
it in districts across New Hampshire
there is a trend that is not going
unnoticed by taxpayers too enrollment in
public schools is going down but School
budgets are going up there are many
factors for this trend but one of those
factors is the administrative budgets
even with school administrators cutting
teachers based on enrollment numbers the
budgets continue to climb in my own
District which is sa 21 we added an
added an assistant superintendent just a
few years ago now we have a
superintendent and two assistant
superintendents and if you look at their
salaries you will see that most of these
administrators make more than the
governor the attorney general and the
commissioner of Education in the state
if you go through their salaries you're
going to find
that everyone I don't know if it's
everyone so just to be clear on
that uh what they do in business is they
look at this all the time how can we
consolidate and again I know that this
is a little different than consolidation
but ups for instance they're constantly
looking at uh they they they combine
districts they they you know they need
drivers to deliver their packages and
they'll take out drivers if they don't
have enough packages but this happens in
business all the time I don't think that
it should be a problem that we're
looking at whether or not this is the
most efficient way for saus to operate
in New Hampshire
uh Northampton where I live our
budget for the the amount that we pay to
our SAU is
$284,000 our cost per pupil in
Northampton which is in elementary and
in middle school is
$339,000 per student that is not the
state number that is the actual number
that's what it costs for us living in
New Hampshire to educate our kids in
Northampton that's a shocking number
needless to
say within SAU 21 we have cab Brook they
will go to the polls in March and decide
if they want to withdraw from the
SAU they just to put it mildly the this
has this school SE Brook has become very
contentious um that is why they're
looking to withdraw from the
SAU the students in C Brook are scoring
around 30% in math and uh I have spoken
before the seab Brook School Board I
have looked at what they're using in the
classroom I have looked at their
curriculum I've looked at their pedagogi
I've looked at everything and I've
brought them some additional
information but if they withdraw this is
going to put
another amount on the rest of us in seu
21 the costs are going up how do we fix
that I don't know I'm not telling you
that I have the answers but a study
committee these study committees that
are being proposed I'm glad that they're
proposing them there's one in in the
Senate too we have got to look at ways
we have got to look at what's going on
in these administrative
units
um we need strong public schools with
good teachers per professionals and
principes if they need an extra
administrator in the school to cover
some of the duties at the SAU level that
would still be able that would still be
a reduction for taxpayers and for um
administrative
costs we looked at cutting $65,000 from
the fire budget fire fighter budget uh
because of the budgets going up in our
town $65,000 the fire Chief came and
spoke to us and said that if that
happens the fire chief and the deputy
fire chief would have to cover two days
a week two days a week out of 52 weeks
that they would have to cover for
firefighters in Northampton and the
reason I bring you that is because when
we're looking at this we're looking at
okay we have a fire budget we have a
town budget we have all these budgets
and if one goes up where are the
teachers in all of this the teachers cuz
I'm not seeing their salaries above what
the governor's making I'm not seeing you
know these are the people are in the
classroom they're the people impacting
the kids and so when I look at a company
like UPS saying you know we're going to
be
efficient I think our schools need to be
efficient too I want to make sure that
we have enough teachers covering the
students and and and anytime a budget's
cut where do they go oh we're going to
get rid of teachers that's the threat
not we're going to bring our salaries in
line at the SAU level to where it's more
you know what you would consider maybe
Fair
um so this is why I support these bills
I I'm only going to speak once on them I
didn't speak on the one that was prior
to this SAU administrators are going to
certainly object they're certainly going
to object this is what we do I'm sure
that there's probably managers at UPS
that were like wait a second you can't
it it happens they consolidate they
consolidate and that's what happens in
the business world and so I think the
most important people in school are our
teachers and our pair of professionals
I'm not afraid to say it I will say it
and I think that when it comes to these
costs going up we've got to start
looking at these budgets
and I'm not seeing outof control
salaries for teachers but when I look at
the salaries for our sa people and I'm
looking at why do we add a second
superintendent assistant superintendent
in our
district I mean really that's that's
that's why I support this so support
these bills that are coming before you
thank you very much for your testimony
any
questions see none thank you very much
Miss
Banfield um with that we'll close the
hearing on uh HB 292
and
um yep we're just about ready uh to
start the hearing on HB
131 um we'll take just a minute
break you are free to do
that oh okay on this
one y
yeah oh
B
[Music]
wow
tells
expression my
take
e
e e
get started again
uh the next and last bill of the day is
HB 131 requiring school boards to
develop and enact policies regarding
personal cell phone use in
schools and um since this is
representative lad day uh he's uh back
at the microphone uh to introduce this
bill do we have a bill to make that
official good afternoon folks uh
represent cordelli and folks of the of
the committee I appreciate your kind
comment I think I've learned my lesson
don't write so many darn bills um uh but
today I I I'm here uh presenting a bill
which this one I feel very very strongly
on uh this bill is HP 131 requiring
School boards to develop and enact
policies regarding personal cell phone
use in schools and when someone sits
down to write legislation like that you
have to always have in your mind at
least I did in the back of my mind where
does State vers local end up on this
thing where can I say this is going to
be a policy that we hope that everybody
follows through the state but am I
intruding upon the responsibility of the
local school board that's a a point that
I think that runs through this bill
however as a state
we are tasked with the
responsibility and our mission to ensure
that all students have the opportunity
to receive an adequate
education that all students leave our
high schools career
ready and that means going on to
postsecondary school going on to a
wonderful job going on to one of the
military branches going on to the job of
your liking and with the skills and the
knowledge that you've been given and
provided with while you were in uh
school so now I'm reflecting a little
bit back on some of the early types of
uh uh uh elements that come from
policies back in the
1980s so I'm dating myself I started
education after I came home from
overseas in Southeast Asia in
1969 and then went into school and
became this teacher which I thoroughly
enjoyed I had to live because I wasn't
getting paid enough and and so that
issue was there but we had this issue we
called time on
task so that's nothing new time spent in
school is not always spent in the
classrooms and time spent in classrooms
is not always spent actively
learning we know that
you can go in and observe what's going
on in a school and get a good feel for a
school by looking at some of the
classrooms and seeing what's going
on time and how it is spent time and
task as we call it may well be a
variable that makes the difference for
students can cell phone use impact time
on task unequivocally yes it can and it
does the amount of time spent actually
uh on learning TX varies greatly from
school to school and from classroom to
classroom a study done Years Ago by the
Michigan State University found that
students in one classroom spent a total
of in this in elementary school 84
minutes a day on
reading but their peers in another
classroom just down the hall spent only
24 minutes a day on the
subject well which classroom do you
think had the best performance
allocate allocated time the time you
have for something is often beyond the
teachers ability to control it's set up
by the schedule within the school
whether you're block scheduling or if
it's a grade school but you know you
have uh a teacher prep period coming up
whether the music teachers coming in or
PE or you got to go to library or
recesses right around the bench so we
have to you know allocate our scheduling
around these designs set up by the
systemwide years and years
go we had within Statute in the state
and over in Maine where I started out
designated minutes per subject per day
per week but we've gotten away from that
since now many subjects override in the
other subject by thematic reading and
and thematic learning all
that
um when teachers give a great deal of
their time and attention to only certain
students
time on task engaged time versus the
allocated time an academic achievement
for the whole class take a
dive now let's get to the business of
this thing we see everybody doing this
you know business with the cell phone
you know you can walk anywhere nowadays
and see it whether you're walking into a
waiting room at a
hospital you can look around and see
everybody waiting what are they doing
they're looking at the cell phone what
are they doing is they're watch walking
down the hallway of a school now used to
be it was a great social experience kids
were yanking around with each other
having fun talking to each other looking
at the whites of the eyes now what are
they looking at the white of the cell
phone they're looking at that cell phone
all the time and that I believe and I'm
not a doctor not a physician but I hear
from my folks saying when I go to
Hitchcock that we're getting more and
more kids in here that have these
physical issues either they bend over or
they're getting this stuff coming on
their cell phones and getting into the
mental emotional issues when they're
getting bullied or that stuff's coming
on or they're looking at pornography or
something on those cell
phones which is really absorbing them
and it's taking them in the wrong
direction I am concerned about cell
phone use in the classroom or in in
schools
this legislation have before you allows
some discretion though it says use
during classroom
instruction that's the part when I'm
teaching my math class or I'm teaching
about the history of New Hampshire I
want those eyeballs where they should be
I don't want them looking down or
feeling the thing buzzing in their
pocket I don't want them looking down to
see who's communicating with them that's
that's ofas behavior and off task
behavior is not learning behavior in
terms of what is being taught the
content how do we control that teachers
have tried teachers believe me they're
trying to control
this however it's bigger now and it has
to come either from the system office
the school board or it's going to have
to come through some statutory
language 72% of high school teachers
said students being distracted by cell
phones is a major
problem that was uh came out education
next in 20125 so that's just reason
article 72% of high school teachers say
this is a
problem when students can readily slip a
phone out during class and access the
entire internet does that not discourage
them from doing the hard work of
learning content again another article
in the paper at at least 14 states have
passed laws or enacted policies that ban
or restrict students use of cell phones
in schools Statewide or recommend local
districts enact their own bans or
restricted policies education week you
know many of us receive education week I
always received it we I still try to get
it and it it's states include Arizona
Alabama Indiana Florida Delaware
Connecticut Minnesota Louisiana
Pennsylvania Oklahoma Ohio South
Carolina Washington and
Virginia so what does this mean if we
have some kind of a policy which I'm
recommending here where they're not used
during instruction but there are
exceptions in this bill right here there
are exceptions for
that there are times when I know there's
certain content areas where an
instructor may say we need to use cell
phones to access this information or we
need this cell phone to access what's
going on in this trade that you're
getting into that you like to get into
and work with that
Association that to me if the cell
phone's out with the permission of the
instructor in the
classroom I have no problem with
that I don't have a problem with it
either if the IEP or 504 plan hasn't
written in the 504 plan or the IEP that
this phone is necessary for this child
to obtain the objectives of this ie
good stuff do it we do it there are
exceptions which should be made I don't
think this should be blank you don't use
your cell phone at all in the
classroom um I think that's an
overreach um so uh I I would say that
some states are doing that large broad
thing you check them in you put them in
a box you lock them up etc etc uh what
do you do in case that the parent calls
and wants to get a hold of them there's
an emergency
what happened when you were kids in
school did you call the office was there
a permission note sent to school saying
hey I'm going to pick up Susan here at 4
o'clock or 3 o' not in the morning in
the afternoon and they won't be able to
participate in the activities after
school today I need to pick them up they
got a dental appointment okay that's the
way you do it or they parent can call
the office but when you're calling and
interrupting that student during class
you're interrupting 25 students you're
interrupting the teacher the teacher is
getting off task off Target and that's
what we don't want we have X number of
minutes in our calendar year we need to
utilize those minutes we don't need to
extend the year we of course they're
doing it down South Carolina where my
daughter is a teacher they're working in
the summertime now but they take time
off when we're probably working
today but I think what we need to do is
we need to utilize time appropriately
accommodations are good but we also have
to remember what this is doing to our
students and it's the the the impacts of
mental and physical health that I'm also
really concerned about when you look at
the IEPs and you see that category out
of the 13 IEP categories other health
impaired why is that ballooning in this
state well I would say and I'm not I
can't prove it but my guess work is has
a lot to do with our social interactions
and the issues brought forth by our
technology and I'm not oppositional
technology I am all for it uh but I I
believe that there's a place and a time
for everything um so I will conclude
with this one last statement here in
2024 a national survey 70% of
participating Educators who teach in
schools that allow cell phones found it
very very disruptive 90% of surveyed
Educators support restricting student
use of cell phones during instructional
time
90% And I think you'll see parents in in
the same wavelength you know parents
really want the the child to receive
everything that school's designed to do
and if we allow this disruptor to
disrupt that we're not going to succeed
so Mr chairman I thank you very much and
I'll be willing to take any questions
thank you uh questions for
representative
lad yes represent Murray thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
um with regard to parent involvement are
you aware that there are already apps
and programs out there that um parents
and children can talk to each other and
um have a conversation about time
management use during the day set time
limits allow certain
uh apps to be used during certain parts
of the
day yeah I am but I'll go back to some
of the research that I found when I
talked to Dr ranuli down at University
of Connecticut who was in charge of the
gifted talented program and Dr ranuli
said your mind's going to be on one
thing at a time you maybe have instance
like that where you can switch back and
forth if that phone is not to be used at
all then the mind is on learning that
history lesson which is going forward so
with all the apps I know what we can do
we can shut them off turn them on Buzz
them do all that um it's it's uh I think
we got to before we lose this thing
totally we need to really support our
teachers in the classroom and teachers
are
asking let us control this give us give
us what we need instructional time is
not where this cell phone should be
unless we allow it and we talked about
that before here with the social media
and all that and we've talked about how
that impacted those people in the Career
Technical education they need it you
know it's just like fixing that stove I
talked about this morning where the cf-2
comes on and where am I going to get the
information to fix it on my cell phone
and that may be the same way it's going
to be when we have some issues discussed
in the classroom especially when you're
talking about diesel mechanics um today
I don't think there's many mechanics
that work without that cell phone but in
the classroom there's some content that
the teacher paid to deliver let the
teacher do it thank
you further questions representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative lad for bringing this
extremely important piece of legislation
forward um in your research have you
been able to find out any statistics on
numbers on how many um instances and um
sites of pornography that high school
students have been accessing
I don't have the the numbers or the
information on we've talked about that
where we've had cross District bullying
going on and uh yeah it it it's it's
horrible what's going on and somehow we
got to stop it and the only way I can do
is turn that switch off thank you
further questions see none thank you
very much thank you represent of
vad next uh
Le
Walco good morning Leo Walo from
Manchester I was a teacher at the high
school level in middle school for about
10 years I had a time in between two
times it wasn't 10 years continuous it
started um in Manchester and then I went
to London Dairy and then I did other
things and then I went back to teaching
again and I ended up back in
Manchester so uh I am in support of this
bill I don't think it even goes far
enough to tell you the truth I would
make it that there was no that's it you
put your phone in in the b in the little
bucket when you walk in the door you'll
pick it up on the way out but I'll take
it if this is what we can do so I want
to talk about three classrooms one is a
girl that taught next to me on this side
of me when I went to Manchester the
first time her name was Lauren and she
taught some of the highest science
classes for sophomores in the
district and when I came back 10 years
later she was still in the same
classroom still teaching the same
classes and I got to talk to her because
she was right next to me and she had had
to abandon entire units of
biochemistry she didn't teach it anymore
because these kids that are destined for
nursing doctors veterinarians Engineers
could no longer do it they could not
comprehend the material they could 10
years earlier but they couldn't now and
she's a good teacher it took her years
to give up on it before she finally
realized it can't be done so this isn't
a problem for one cohort of kids that's
what happened to my nextd door neighbor
to the highest kids in Manchester
then I'll talk about my classroom my
classroom when I came back I would
taught like the middle middle area kids
they're attract mine were all going to
college some of them thought they were
going much higher than they probably
could because of the level that they
were in but they had aspirations some of
them quite
high and in February the last year I
taught at Memorial High School out of
desperation I took my own February
vacation and I called every single
parent of all of my students I started
with the fs and I made my way up the
list Susie is a great kid love to have
her in class super fun personality
unfortunately Susie's failing and uh you
know we can do something about it though
I notice she's on her phone a lot and I
bought one of these shoe organizers the
clear ones that you can see through and
I'm going to hang it on my wall right
near the door and if you want I'll put
your name on the list that Susie knows
she has to deposit her phone when she
walks in my door and because she was
failing susy's mommy said yes and so I
went the fs and then the D's and then
the C's and by the time I got to the B's
I was able to say you know Jeff Jeff
doesn't have any problem but he too
would benefit from a more organized
classroom time and I got unanimity and I
became an urban legend I had kids that I
had never had kids that were taking
senior science that were never my
student that came in they wanted to see
it it had become that big of a
story so I didn't know this bill existed
if I did in time if I had known in time
I would have gone and I would have dug
through my things but I kept the records
of what happened and we were going into
the lower end of the year like summer is
around the bend start to fall off but my
scores went up they went up across the
board I wish I had the actual figures
here for you but I can tell you that it
was across the board everybody did
better they had a hard time adjusting it
wouldn't have been as hard for them if
it wasn't a single classroom that this
was happening but they're addicted
they're chemically physically addicted
the phones were built to be addictive
they the people that created this
technology have said so themselves it
was built so that you can't leave it
alone so it isn't only time off task
that we could literally sit there and
measure with a with a little stopwatch
it's that when a 14-year-old's mind
whose attention is so fragile now so
fragile when it's broken because that
thing vibrates you there's no way to
measure how many minutes if at all they
ever are able to bring their attention
truly back to Bear of what we're talking
about it it it can be gone for good in
in a single me let me see text it back
oh smiley face whatever it is it's gone
so it's not measurable the loss in
learning
time the last person I want to talk
about is the guy that was on the other
side of me he was there when I started
he was there when I returned and he was
teaching the lowest level freshman
science classes and because it became a
thing of urban legend there was a lot of
talk in the science department about
this crazy thing that I had done he
didn't want it done because and I don't
even blame him the behavior in the
classroom is so bad that he said at
least they're quiet and the few kids
that he could hope to try to work on a
lesson with could be down front and the
others could be in the back zombified on
their
phone
so here's the thing it's our fault it's
the adults fault that this is happening
you cannot expect an addicted
13-year-old child to be able to leave it
alone they can't and so we need to be
the adults in the room we need
to I I I don't believe we need to be
able to use a phone but fine you you
want to say that there are some lessons
that they all need to be on their phone
I'm not going to try to derail it for
that
but if you don't pass something like
this nothing else you do here is going
to matter it isn't going to matter what
the curriculum is what the supports are
how long the day is what kind of uh
whatever because they're not there if
they're not there they can't be reached
I don't care what book you use what
method you teach so as a teacher because
you kind of always are it's got that SFI
type of thing right once a teacher
always a teacher for the benefit of my
colleagues that are still in the
trenches and for the benefit of these
poor young people who have no ability
to we can't even do it I've watched some
people in here sitting on their phone we
can't do it and we didn't come up with
our brains interfacing with this
technology and we can't do it so I I
strongly urge you to pass this bill or
make it even
stronger if you have any questions I'll
take thank you very much uh questions
possibly yes Cornell Thank you thank you
for taking my well it's a question
statement do you know that Manchester
has passed a cell phone electronic
policy and they have to be put away at
the beginning of the day all day long be
taken out I don't know I think that's
awesome I I know that they
were I had a I had one of the school
board members can't is it is it new it's
it's pretty recent yeah that's that's
yeah better late than never
yeah yeah uh further questions
yes represent Morris yeah I think I
already know the answer for this one but
may as well
ask if you could change anything in here
to make it even more as you say
restrictive what would it be the
language in the
bill I would um I would take out these
exceptions and I would just say that the
the phones are not to be um I don't
think they should be seen during the
school day I really don't
you know the the thing he discussed
about them walking down the hall and
talking to each other it isn't only in
those 3 minutes in between classes when
they pass which is really some of their
major socializing time it isn't only
then it's at lunch they just sit lost in
a dream they're not there they're not
able to like learn how to share a meal
with people personally if I if I had it
my way I would have it you put your
phone away it not to be seen in the day
at all you pick it up at night when you
leave the building you know parents get
freaked out because we're addicted and
now we've gotten to these habits of we
don't like deal with what needs to be
dealt with before school in the morning
we want to be able to text oh do you
need a ride oh you know did you get this
picked up or whatever and there there
can be some you know out outcry that
people are so addicted to this way of
communicating that they they don't like
the idea of a change but I'm confident
that we'll be fine you know we raised
kids before without being able to text
them I caught that one though I caught
him and we called him Walter White after
that further
questions cenan thank you very much for
being here and for your
testimony uh next would be uh
superintendent McGee and um Cameron one
of the
students so first off thank you very
much for uh allowing us to be here my
name is Chip McGee I'm the
superintendent of schools in the pelum
school district
um uh it's wonderful to have uh Cameron
Marvin here he's an eighth grader um I'm
just going to do a very brief
introduction and then he's going to do
most of the speaking um so the pal
Memorial School our Middle School um
enacted a program to have cell phones
not just off in a way but uh locked in a
way uh during the school day uh at the
beginning of this school year uh and so
there was some concern in the community
um but uh uh we went ahead with this
program and um I would tell you uh I
could have done a data presentation
there's very good data about fewer
incidents in the bathrooms um uh
increased time on task uh a great
satisfaction from teachers um uh but uh
when we were putting a presentation for
the board together Cameron offered to
speak um uh and uh when I saw this bill
come forward I was very excited um I'm
in support of it uh and uh I asked uh
Cameron whether he would dust off what
he said and uh prepare it for uh this
group um and so I think his firsthand
experience is going to be um uh far more
uh interesting than anything an old
superintendent would say so
Cameron thank you to committee chair
cordelli and vice chair Noble for the
opportunity to to speak to you
today thank you to all the
representatives of Ed education policy
and administration my name is Cameron
Marvin I'm an eighth grader at pal
Memorial School this year we implemented
the use of Y pouches within our policy
to restrict the use of personal cell
phones during the school day I wanted to
share my experience as a student with
the new pouches so
far since I'm a teenager I definitely do
not like getting up for school every day
once I'm there I like school and I
really like our teachers one of the
hardest adjustments I've had to make
while starting Middle School was dealing
with all the distractions within the
classrooms these major distractions were
mostly from kids using their
phone they were not only distracting
while doing it but they had to be spoken
to which interrupted the class sometimes
this would be multiple times a class and
it is frustrating when class has to stop
so much the teachers were trying to talk
but they would have to pause frequently
because they caught someone using their
phone it made it really hard to focus on
what they were saying or do enterpr work
many times kid kids would have
to kids would have their phones open and
check Snapchat show others videos
texting playing games or sometimes even
taking some photos or
videos it was every single day when you
went into the restroom there would
always be someone in there on the phone
or a group of people using them I would
see a lot of destructive behavior in the
restrooms because some kids think it's
funny to record while doing something
wrong having the ability to record the
behavior and show it off to uh to show
it off would give kids more of the
temptation to do it since Yonder started
this year classes have been much more
calm and I can definitely see it and
feel it every day
with Yonder the temptation to use the
phone in class is not there because no
one has access to it the kids are not
getting in trouble in class as much and
the teachers can teach the whole class
without having to tell someone to put
their phones away or send them to the
office the good thing is that you don't
see just one person standing out and
being punished with their phone taken
away everyone is equal and everyone has
to do the same thing with their phone no
one has that extra pressure the stress
of using a restroom break has gone away
I used to be afraid of what I would walk
into I would be afraid that if something
was damaged I would walk in on it and it
was happening or I would have have to be
questioned later because I signed out to
use the
restroom since the kids cannot use their
phones they cannot record any behaviors
to show off to
others that has kept a lot of kids from
even attempting half of the things they
they used to do when people ask me how
it's going with Yonder the main
description I can give is that it's more
peaceful there's a huge weight lifted
off our shoulders the phones are out of
sight and everyone knows it so in a way
it makes the day much
calmer I love that I can pay more
attention when the teacher is talking it
is very hard to focus when the teacher
is explaining a lesson or directions
while a few kids next year are sneaking
on the phone
I used to leave school stressed out on
many days because I couldn't focus in
class school does not come easy to me
and I have to pay I have to pay
attention and work hard for all my
grades with all the Tik toks being made
videos or photos taken and all the kids
sneaking their phones it was stressful
when trying so hard to pay
attention I could tell that the teachers
did their best to keep the cell phones
away but let me tell you something
something a 13-year-old is really good
at hiding
it teachers can't see every single thing
while uh talking in front of the room
I'm not really sure how anyone could
ever teach if they had to be looking for
phones the whole
class in the beginning kids were very
vocal and annoyed about the
pouches but I think that is because we
don't know enough about it I'm on the
football team in palum as well as the
baseball
team and I am also in the Middle School
band
because of that I have a very diverse
group of friends classmates and
teammates many that I have heard
opinions from do not mind and say that
they appreciate it
now the fact that that the pressure of
the temptation to use the phone even for
a quick second is gone makes things much
more
calm the office always allows us to call
a parent if we need to talk to them
about something important such as rid
homes rise home or if something is
canceled after school that is something
the kids and parents can feel good about
I know this is an official survey or
anything but when talking to my friends
and classmates they don't mind it
anymore I've seen firsthand the negative
effects of cell phone usage in
class since the start of this program
I've yet to see any negative effects of
restricting the phone
use with this being said I feel that HB
131 should pass and the school boards
within the state should adopt a policy
in order to govern student cell phone
cell phone use in schools like we have
done in pelum thank
you good J thank
you thank you very much Cameron for your
testimony um it was uh very interesting
um I I had one question um what was the
reaction when you said about um use of
these pouches particularly among parents
you me and then you sure uh so as the
superintendent uh there was um uh pretty
significant reaction um uh some uh about
equal measure thank goodness I really
appreciate as some of the the testimony
we've already heard um and uh then some
uh don't or uh very upset about um uh
encroachment on freedom or safety issues
or security issues and so we had to work
through
those um and uh it was something that I
was grateful that the community and uh
my school board uh supported um
so reactions when you first heard about
it um I
mean there
was a bunch of mostly kids that didn't
really like it cuz
it's it's an addiction and um it
is it is frustrating when you when kids
don't have their phones for a certain
period of
time but um I started to to actually
like like it and um see the use of
it
um and how everybody else is reacting to
it too so I one other thing which is uh
we we still have uh frequent petitions
from students to try and get it
overturned um that the the tension is
still there it's not like it's happily
ever
after thank you uh questions represent L
fields thank you chairman and thank you
both for being here today Cameron you
were wonderful you were articulate
concise convincing you should be a
spokesman for Yonder and you've got the
the hair too I I think
so I'm so happy that you brought this up
and I have to tell you that admittedly
so I think I'm addicted to because as
you were talking I have a bill cell
phone bill as well I wanted to grab my
phone and look it up during your test
and it's hard to just step back and say
no so I wanted to ask you about Yonder
because I have the Yonder paperwork too
and the bill that I'm bringing forward I
wanted to get your opinion please um it
was a grant grant money which I know is
like taboo because it's budget season
right it was a $250,000 Statewide grant
for schools to apply because the Yonder
pouches are about $30 per head exactly
$30 right and I understand that um for
the administrator well for the teachers
it can be very uncomfortable to have to
police this throughout the day and just
like we heard the kids do have the dummy
phones right with all the upgrades hand
the dummy phone um so my question to you
is what do you think about that because
I was thinking this would help gain
momentum with positive testimonials and
it would gain contaction throughout the
state and I'm I'm sorry that it wasn't
available when you did this yeah so um
uh I would say speaking only from our
experience uh uh I'm not here in terms
of speaking for other districts but uh
in at pel Memorial School it was a
transformative impact and it's because
it is locked in a way and I would add in
the students possession so we're not
taking a $600 device away from them um
all day um uh but they can't access it
uh it's also very smooth to operate I
feel like a spokesman for the company
but it is one of the uh few uh tools
that I found in in schools that had an
instant uh and high value
impact
follow just quickly too would you mind
Shar my my understanding is limited but
my understanding is that you carry the
pouch and then there are magnets
throughout the School wherever the
children are allowed to use Excuse me
students you're not a child um the exits
or wherever you do you just touch this
magnet with your pouch and and it opens
up or how does that work so the magnet
um when it there's like a
little piece at the top that actually
connects it and when you use the
magnet um there's a mechanism inside
that releases it when you press onto
it I'm not one 100% sure how it works
you know those things that uh they put
on cloes so you don't shoplift and that
people can take off of uh the the clerk
can take off um I would also tell you
that now that students have been doing
it for uh this year it it literally
takes a student less than a second um to
get it unlocked um and you don't need
the magnet to lock
it yes represent Woodcock thank you once
again thank you as I'm sure I also say
the same thing for your presentation and
coming here it's terrific to see a
student speaking um just a a question
how Cameron how did you happen to know
about this
bill
um he's being nice I told
him you didn't find there any phone
there okay all right thank you I was
just curious CU how student responded
thank you he he called him on the phone
yeah I
texted uh represent Murray thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
and thanks for the question I just
wanted to be clear um we're also talking
about um the instance when uh phones are
also medical devices does this that's a
really great question um so uh as uh
representative Vlad uh mentioned um any
accommodation whether it's for a special
education a medical accommodation uh
disability 504 all of those are
exceptions and there's a very clear proc
well we already have those processes and
we we made it clear up front there will
be exceptions people use it for uh
diabetes for example tracking and those
those are exceptions and they have to
be U representative McDonald thank you
Mr chair and thank you both for being
here this was very helpful Cameron uh
but my question is probably better
directed at you the superintendent um
the policy seems to be working in pelum
would this bill require you to adopt a
new policy or you already comping with
what this bill would say uh we are
compliant and uh I will editorialize
that just from my personal point of view
um the the the proposed Bill simply
doesn't go as far as needed um uh the
exceptions as enforced by teachers uh is
too much to ask of teachers okay thank
you represent
Hall oh thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so there are
exceptions for 504's IEP are there
exceptions for the Educators themselves
if it's a science class and they want
the kids to be doing data on their phone
no that's not acceptable no we so we we
are fortunate that we students have
devices they have Chromebooks uh the the
radical difference I would say to the
committee is that a cell phone accesses
data through a cellular network that's
unfiltered uh a Chromebook Chromebook
accesses data through our Network that
is filtered um and uh so uh I don't
really see any place where accessing
data through uh an unfiltered cell phone
is appropriate in the school setting
thank you representative Terry thank you
I can't see you but I know you're there
oh there you are
now uh thank you Cameron for your uh
testimony today I I
think it's so helpful uh to have
students come from time to time when
there are issues that impact them
directly and this is not the first
instance where we've had students come
and testify but I think it's so
important that we hear directly from you
and others because you're the ones who
are being um uh affected adversely in a
very significant way I don't want to
forget the teachers in this instance but
um but thank you very much we don't want
to to overlook or lose your voice
um I'm wondering how long the policy has
been in place at at pum sir
and what your observation would be
provided it's been more than a week or
two what what's your observation with
respect to how this is impacting either
positively or
negatively uh student academic
performance so uh in terms of timeline
we uh implemented this right at the
beginning of this school year um so
August 23rd I believe um uh and in terms
of impact uh I don't know yet uh uh from
a uh State assessment point of view
that's in the spring um but that is one
of the intents of this is to improve
academic performance I do know that our
diagnostic testing which is called I
ready um uh has has shown some
preliminary indications of a positive
direction but I can't draw that
conclusion yet and I don't know if you
had anything about impact on academics
consistently outstanding so doesn't make
any differ representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
both for coming in front of us
especially you Mr mavin you did a
wonderful job very very well very
applaud you for that um I have a
question about behavior issues um in the
past and and currently what you're
seeing superintendent could you tell me
if you're seeing any Improvement in
behavior issues yeah so uh so the
definitive answer is yes
um uh so uh as measured by um Discipline
matters related to the bathroom um as
Cameron spoke about um but I'd go one
step further which is to say the uh the
principal uh wonderful principal at pel
Memorial School name is Zach Medlock uh
he disagreed with me two years ago
pretty completely that uh that this was
an issue because if you walk to the
Halls two years ago you did not see a
cell phone problem um because
13-year-olds are good at hiding it um so
it happened out of out of view um and uh
he he has changed 180 degrees um uh and
he'll admit it he kind of wanted uh uh
to just let the let the kids learn
through experience was his argument um
uh and he said we did have a problem I
just couldn't see it um so Less in the
bathroom um uh but also I think the the
discussion of time on task is really
significant
many fewer interruptions wonderful
followup Mr chair yes thank you would
you believe there was a time that when I
was in high school that you could smoke
cigarettes in the courtyard and we
rallied against that when they outlawed
it and guess what they were right yeah
so I appreciate that I think the analogy
to cigarettes is um apt thank you so
much repr Woodcock thank you J cell for
allowing me do this superintendent just
a question this is the middle school I'm
not familiar with the PM system yep I'm
assuming there's a high school there is
is there is your intention to move this
progress through the whole school system
yeah so um uh I uh had said from the
moment we put it in place at Memorial
that I intended to put it in the high
school um The High School uh Student
Government um very skillfully organized
themselves um to make the case that they
can police themselves um and so uh the
principal uh at the high school Don me
and I have given them a a year reprieve
um but we will put it in place um uh if
and when we see it to be necessary but
they did ask as high school students can
they uh can so we switched to off and
Away there this year it used to be you
could have it out now it's off and away
just like Manchester um and so we have
I'm not planning next year to implement
it but I will as soon as uh the
principal and I see it necessary thank
you any further questions uh thank you
very much both of you for being here
today thank
you Gary
Hoffman
child kids at
lunch have the lunch
talks to
do else to do
yeah Gary Hoffman I live in Nash New
Hampshire and I rise in support of this
legislation I am the President of the
nasua teachers union and uh I represent
approximately 1,000 teachers uh in the
NASA School District as well as an
additional 400 uh School support staff
and I just want to first uh thank
representative lad for crafting this
bill I think it's a good good bill uh it
gives school districts a little bit of
leeway um it puts exemptions for 504s
and I AP so if a student has a re a
learning disability that requires cell
phone use or a medical exemption that
would be like in a 504 often times this
bill allows that um and so you know I I
think that this is really needed this
shouldn't be a controversial bill I mean
many countries have banned cell phones
we have France Brazil the Netherlands
Italy Portugal Finland even China have
restricted cell phone use in schools for
students the United Nations last year
put out a report warning about the
dangers of uh cell phone use by students
and schools so I think it's time that
New Hampshire pass something similar my
school district the teachers have asked
for a bill like this um and in fact this
year our high schools organized
themselves and um they uh they just
conducted a survey that we're going to
be sharing with our superintendent
assistant superintendent to get teacher
attitudes at the high school level
regarding cell phone use and
204 uh sorry 210 High School uh teachers
did take this uh cell phone survey and I
would just like to share some of the
results of the survey now this survey
was created by an AP psychology teacher
Paul Menard as well as a longtime vure
an English teacher and member of my
executive board uh Walter Freeman and
representative uh representative Freeman
uh our teacher Walter Freeman actually
said something similar that you just did
about cigarette
smoking but uh you know he he actually
said I think that in 20 years we're
going to look at giving unfettered cell
phone access to students um really in
the same way that 40 years ago we had
smoking stations and schools I mean 4
years
now but I think that was about the time
was the early 80s where they started to
go away was 1979 really okay I was close
from high school all
right well I think I I think your
analogy really worked well though um
they are addictive but uh when the when
the survey results came through the the
210 High School teachers responded this
way uh 89 9.6% of them agreed that cell
phone access lowered student
concentration with
64.8% strongly agreeing
86.7% of the respondents agreed that
cell phones hindered students ability to
complete lengthy assignments and
58.6% strongly
agreed um
82.8% of the respondents agreed that
cell phones red reduce peer engagement
with 53% strongly agreeing
and
89.5% agreed that cell phones interfered
with self-directed learning and 60%
strongly agreed with that statement now
in the Nashua School District the
current uh the current policy if we we
don't really have anything formal is
basically it's teacher discretion but we
surveyed that amongst High School
teachers and 69% of the respondents
reported dissatisfaction with their
ability to for uh phone related
expectations in their own classrooms so
it sort of Echoes what some of the
previous uh speakers said you know
teachers would like to enforce this uh
cell you know enforce cell phone use in
their classrooms but increasingly
they've had a really tough time because
they are so
addictive um so I just I don't want to
take a lot of your time but I did want
to lend my voice as a person that did
teach for 22 years in the Nashwood
school district and currently on leave
as a representative of the Nashua
teachers union I'm letting you know that
the Thousand or so teachers in the
Nashua School District would appreciate
this and we really thank the authors of
this legislation I'll entertain any
questions representative dry thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um in the middle of this bill
it says districts are encouraged to
consider exceptions to student use
during instruction so it doesn't close
the door to prohibiting it is that still
not good enough in your mind or is that
okay my personal uh Viewpoint as a
teacher was is it doesn't go far enough
however I'm smart enough to know that
it's probably more likely that this
would pass with that exception um there
might be some very strong feelings about
having stronger language um I I think
for a first step this is this is a good
policy as written
further questions representative Freeman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in front of us so what I heard
you say is that there are a lot of
teachers in Nashville are having an
issue with this and it's not a new issue
it's something that's been ongoing and
the one question I I I'm going to ask
you is um have you gone in front of your
school board and express these concerns
to
them so we follow chain of command and
our teachers right now are have formed a
committee with our assistant
superintendent with the blessing of our
superintendent to research this issue
and we are hoping that these survey
results will um get our our our central
office administration on board I think
they're going to get there and we were
planning to craft a policy together to
take to the school board because we know
uh any policy we bring forward is going
to happen have a lot more weight if we
do it with uh the superintendent
assistant superintendent of
schools yes repr Sal thank you so much
um so I the two-part question I guess
the the first part
is I mean I'm in a district that already
has a cell phone policy as a district um
which we've had our own hiccups with but
do you think that we need a state
mandate for this or do you think that
local control around making these
policies is sufficient
the state policy will help teachers all
throughout New Hampshire enforce this if
we can tell our students oh this is just
state law that will help us so much it
really will honestly and we would love
your backing on this ask a follow follow
um and I I know like I'm from a district
that's fortunate enough where students
are issued Chromebooks or other devices
to be able to
use we have that in n as well is that
something that's Universal across New
Hampshire or do we have districts that
can't afford to provide those to their
students where if they need to access
research that they might not be able to
get to within the classroom that having
that access would make it more
available well I can only speak
specifically to nashua's uh 10,000
students we have one toone access at the
secondary level the middle and high
school levels and I believe we're
getting to that level at the elementary
um but the beauty of this bill is if you
have a community that is in that
situation and there may be some um it
does offer uh for instructional use only
on teacher discretion they might be able
to craft a policy to kind of get where
you're getting at um but you know that's
a really I don't know to rely on
personal student devices you know that's
an incredibly unfair thing because you
know certain kids are going to have
iPhone 17s others you know might not
barely have anything um so I I I hope
that the state wouldn't that that
wouldn't be something we would hope to
rely and I hope that we would uh strive
to get one toone Computing eventually
further questions see none thank you
very much Mr Hoffman hey thank you Brian
Hawkins uh
going for the hatrick today Mr chairman
um so um thank you uh for your time for
the record Brian Hawkins representing
Nea New Hampshire um we are in support
of a state law that would require uh
this type of minimum standard for school
districts to adopt a policy restricting
uh Pro uh or prohibiting cell phone use
in our schools and I some of the
previous speakers I think captured
really well um you know the reasons for
that and so I won't repeat those um uh
Nea uh nationally recently conducted a
nationwide survey of its members and
found that 90 90% of NAA members
supported a school policy prohibiting
cell phone uh personal devices during an
instructional time and 83% supporting uh
prohibiting during the entire school day
um and some of the takeaways included
that cell phone banss in schools were
proliferating in the face of mounting
evidence that devices are taking a
serious toll on students ability to
focus in the classroom uh and their
overall mental health um there are a lot
of District policies out there but many
of them can be vague and inconsistent
and in some cases difficult to enforce
and so a lot of local educator unions
are trying to advocate for um tougher
and more uh uniform approaches that will
allow them to spend more time teaching
their classrooms and less time being
cell phone police um in anticipation of
this issue being a significant topic the
session uh any New Hampshire did survey
over the winter break uh some of our
local leaders uh specifically asking
about whether their District had a
policy and sort of some follow-up
questions depending on you know whether
they did or didn't um and just to
summarize that
um uh the the noticeable Trend with
those responses was um that the um first
that it did make a positive difference
in their school um for those of who did
but especially those who had a
restriction that lasted throughout the
school day and not just uh during
instructional time and a representative
lad did a good job I think describing
that you know it's not just absolutely
the instructional time but Al also that
the socialization time
um hallways lunchroom Etc so um
specifically to the bill I'll go
specifically to the bill um
uh we would just want to comment on some
of the language that's been brought up
uh specifically about uh such policy
shall restrict the use of student
personal cell phone use during class
instruction without educator approval
Our concern here um would be that this
sort of uh puts too much into um the
individual uh educator or teachers hands
to be uh the cell phone police and so
that's where I think if you did go
broader I would say that lasting
throughout the school day would be one
way to um uh to address this um if um
opportunities when
students uh can use cell phones in a
class are needed this should probably
probably be uh based on the school
policy and at the administrative level
and not at the classroom level um and it
should be consistent throughout the
school um another thing we found too was
within a school district you may have
one school say the middle school that
has a complete you know ban on cell
phone use but maybe not the high school
and we've heard from some of our locals
where they said at the high school they
want the Middle School's um policy and
so we've heard that too um and then the
second piece I wanted to raise about the
bill was the exceptions um and I do
think that um with respect to so so that
goes to the sentence about on line five
about districts being encouraged to
consider
exceptions um rather than that sentence
I think it um the the the the last
sentence um I think those exceptions are
important um I would add to those uh
multilanguage uh multilingual Learners
as as one of those exceptions because I
do know that they're in addition to the
the superintendent earlier brought up
medical needs as well so um but the
principles I'll just leave with you with
that I think are important from some of
the surveying that we've done is that is
is Bell to Bell is is important uh it
does make and I think it does make it
easier to
enforce
um of the people who I may be repeating
myself but of the people who did have
policies restricting them during
instructional times the occasional time
where we would see someone say it did
not make as much of a
difference uh having having a
prohibition was when it was
instructional time only and not
throughout the school day so um but
overall it was a it was a positive
impact um and so um
I'll the the other thing I would leave
you with is
um you know some of the reactions from
Individual reactions that we got from
our uh members who do have these
policies uh were really encouraging and
a couple of them that stood out to me
was about the school building being just
more calm uh less tense um the issues
about cyber bullying you know doesn't
cure them all but uh
the superintendent from pelum earlier I
think brought up some of these examples
that we've seen in other schools uh and
I think um so I I would Echo all of
those and uh but again we support this
type of a bill and happy to work with
the committee to make sure it's
something that um is good for all
students in New Hampshire thank
you thank you
thank you again chairman cordelli uh
members of the committee bar Christina
school boards Association uh we didn't
specifically take a position on the on
the bill but we we certainly um support
uh efforts to uh restrict cell phone
bans uh in schools uh just a little bit
of brief history um uh nhba does have a
sample policy on on on electronic
communication devices um I are my notes
say that we revised in 2006 I don't have
any specific recollection of that but I
do remember I um uh in 2010 uh we
revised to basically prohibit electronic
communication devices and we called
electronic communication devices because
before cell phones we had kids that had
pagers and beepers some of you remember
may may remember those um uh and so we
our our sample policy initially did
Implement a ban basically Bell to Bell
if you will um the administrators liked
it was some push back from parents
obviously for some of the reasons that
that that have have been discussed
Safety and Security and it's my device
and you can't take it things of that
nature um we have not revised the sample
policy primarily because I think
districts um have been able to navigate
that on themselves we heard from from
pum representative Cornell uh mentioned
that Manchester has a pretty robust
policy that that I've looked at um so
you know and I also had initial concerns
about you know is it one more thing for
for school boards to do but certainly
here in the testimony today I think it's
undeniable that um that some sort of
restriction or or ban on cellones
limiting student use during the school
day is going to be um beneficial um for
staff students and and and primarily for
for the students um representative
litfield I did see your bill as well too
we like that yours has the appropriation
representative Lads does not um uh so uh
you know these these are not inexpensive
you know some districts can afford
Yonder pouch as other districts we know
it's going to be a fiscal challenge for
them um but uh anyway um you know we
certainly work with the committee if
there are any amendments if you want um
you know I the one thing that I think is
beneficial for this is that I I forget
who it was that mentioned is now School
boards can point to the law and say
parents we have an obligation an
obligation to do this and and we'll sort
of craft that craft a policy um in line
with whatever whatever language comes
out of this bill or representative
litfield Bill one last point that I do
want to mention representative Terry you
asked um superintendent McGee if uh
palum had seen any academic Improvement
yet and he said it was a little bit too
soon to to identify that I was at a
conference in Providence Rhode Island
back in September and there was a uh a
presentation from a principal at a
middle school in Providence and they had
just wrapped up two years of cell phone
bans he said and they again middle
school so ages what 11 to 14 or so he
said in the two years that they had
implemented this this ban they were
using the Yonder pouches um they saw
instances of bullying go down because
instances of bullying went down there
were fewer fist fights in the cafeteria
in the locker room because there was
less bullying and fewer fist fights
student attendance went up because
student attendance went up there was
more time on task because there was more
time on task there was an academic um uh
an undeniable academic improvement with
Stu with student performance so um we
think that you know we think that
limiting the use of these cell phones
within the school district can alleviate
a lot of what I'll just call social ills
or societal ills while simultaneously
increasing student outcomes and student
performance so um we're happy to work
with the legislature um if you want to
see some sample policies I can I can
pass those those on to Jen but um uh
that's my testimony thank you thank you
very much questions from the committee
yes representative Bon thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm just wondering if you have
a sense of how many school districts do
have policies in place at this time yeah
thank you very much we don't track that
representative we send it out you know
our sample policies out but we don't
track which districts um uh adopt which
policies that also is I I believe it's
an optional policy um I forget if we
categorize it optional or recommended so
an optional policy it's impossible to
know yeah further questions
representative Terry yes uh thank you
and uh thank you for mentioning um what
you learned at the conference in Rhode
Island um I I lived in Rhode Island for
over 30 years and um witnessed as a
apparent a real deterioration in um
academic performance student behavior
and so forth uh in the Providence metro
area particularly and so I was very
heartened to hear you provide that
additional information thank you I'm
glad I could do that sir
yes representative litfield thank you
and thank you for taking my question
certainly um so you may not be the best
person to ask but I know at least you
know many of the PO sample policies that
you have out there and looking at the
exceptions regarding um I don't know
let's say it's necessary for an IP or a
504 often times is it already in school
policy that the child would be assigned
um like a district device or something
if they needed it for IEP yeah that's a
good question representative thank you
very much
um you know without wasting the
committee's more time I don't know that
Becky would answer the special ed aspect
to that I know our sample policy I I
mean I can tell you anecdotally I think
some school districts do provide a
device to a child I don't know if it's
necessarily a cell phone or maybe a
tablet of some sort but yeah I think
that can I I just anecdotally I think
that's certainly been wrapped into IEPs
and the district maybe paying for some
of those for for some for some some
students and kids
yeah uh thank you Mr Taran thanks for
taking my question in the in the event
of um assisted technology for learning
that's that's one conversation but in
the event of like a another device um
that would be collecting medical data to
monitor a health condition that's often
housed on a personal medical device uh
within a phone is that correct thank you
for the question I have no idea
that that's outside of my scope of
knowledge yes represent Cel thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
so first I I know for example my kids I
AP has are allowed to take out her
device for music during tests so that
she can focus on the test and how one
aspect of ADHD works but are there
districts that you're aware of where if
they brought in these policies they
would need financial support to be able
to have some kind of device for storing
phones or or some some type of like that
wouldn't be able to that don't
necessarily already have money in their
budget for these kinds of things that
would need State support to be able to
make that happen sure thank thank thank
you for the question representative um
so as the bill is written no it does not
require districts to purchase any
technology or equipment to implement a
cell phone ban I'm just going to call it
a cell phone ban and we not get into the
between class and lunch and and all that
um that would be primarily a local
decision with how a district wanted to
one craft their policy and to what um
what measures or steps a district would
want to take to ensure compliance and
enforcement with the policy now just
hearing the testimony and what little I
know of the conference I was at yes the
the Yonder bag is probably the best way
to ensure compliance with the policy for
districts that don't have the money to
purchase a called a device or equipment
similar the Yonder or the bag there's
going to be have to be education
training and parental buyin and I should
also say too just this this just jumped
on on my on jumped in my head in reading
a sample policy from somewhere um and I
don't want to derail this I really don't
but are we going to include smart
watches with cell
[Music]
phones per should have kept his mouth
shut I'm just saying represent Freeman
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
um and and correct me if I'm wrong but I
I I'm pretty sure I distinctly heard
somebody say that there is a grant that
is available for about
$250,000 that so you did hear that as
well if I may representative correct me
if I'm wrong representative
representative litfield has a similar
bill and I forget the S somewhere in the
700s I forget the bill number
representative I think it just came out
yesterday maybe sure but you're not
touching your device
fantastic um I I I was looking at it
earlier representative Lichfield has a
similar bill and I believe the language
is exactly the same except for the fact
that representative Lichfield seeks to
appropriate
$250,000 on some sort of competitive
Grant if if if you will that districts
can apply for to get some money to
offset the cost of these pouches don't
let my my smartphone comment um derail
this um I you have my word that you know
when we're looking at
policy Statewide if a local District
wants to include smartphones on that
they can without having to to to Tinker
with with the proposed bill or there are
any
legislation thank you very much uh see
no further questions we thank you and uh
call up next Dan Marie
Banfield this chair
okay so
uh I do come here in support of HB
131 uh years ago we were told by
education reformers that students didn't
need to know their math facts and
calculators were the new technology that
would replace the need for students to
memorize math facts that did
happen um that fad harmed math education
in this country like many fads that
sometimes filter through the public
schools today there are more feds than
filtering through the public schools too
to profit technology the industry not to
help
students we all know that cell phones in
class are distractions for students we
know that they certainly do not help
students
learn there may be exceptions for
students who have special needs but for
the average student in school they've
become distractions and I do I do
appreciate that there are exceptions in
here medical reasons um 504 or things
like that I think it needs to be
flexible we don't want a one size fits
all uh but I feel the same is true for
the one toone devices that students now
use in school and at home to complete
their
homework I believe it's a matter of time
before we finally acknowledge the
mistake of replacing books and textbooks
with Chromebooks and iPads it was a
money maker again for the technology
industry but not always good for
taxpayers and students and I'm happy to
elaborate on this serious negative
impact at the end if if you would if you
would like um so I do think that
removing phones is a good step cell
phones do not have to be removed
entirely but during class time it should
definitely
be some have said that banning cell
phones in class will be hard to enforce
but I heard a great solution to that one
teacher reported that in her school if a
cell phone is taken away from the
student because they are breaking the
rules the parent must pick it up that
pretty much ends that that right away if
you have to have the parent coming in
every day to pick up the cell phone that
the kid's using a lot of times that
resolves itself Sweden is going in the
direction of eliminating technology in
school they say that it has created
students who do not know basic skills
there's clear scientific evidence that
digital tools impair rather than enhance
student learning Sweden's Carol kolinska
Institute a highly respected Medical
School focused on Research search said
in a statement in August on the
country's National digitalization
strategy and education the push for
technology in the classroom began with
Essa when it was signed into
law um I have no doubt that the
technology industry made sure that that
provision was in the federal law it's a
profit maker it's a data Miner when it
come at high school where I live
students unplugged from their digital
devices for a day to raise awareness
about how technology impacts their life
uh I was really pleased to to know that
our superintendent had had supported
this and I'll read to you some of their
findings on the se21 website if you
would like to go look at them yourself
I'm going to condense them I'm not going
to read the entire thing we do not have
to live without technology and that's
certainly not what I'm suggesting as it
can enhance our lives but after many
years of experimenting on CH children
there are a great deal of negative
complications implications that come
from screen
time so uh if you go to the sau21
website I'm just going to read the
highlighted Parts you can read the
entire thing on on the website do do you
have that in written maybe you just
submit that okay will answer some of the
questions that you had impact okay yeah
let me just do this real quick teachers
were teachers were encouraged to
integrate phone and laptop free
activities in class throughout the day
the library had board game and puzzles
and students played trivia at lunch it
was very heartwarming and eye opening
experience um this is from some of the
people I also enjoyed seeing everyone's
face in the hallway and had much fun
during lunch playing trivia and really
connecting with my friends and teachers
um yeah I I'll turn this in I'll I'll
just I'll leave it at that um one oh one
complaint I did well I don't know if
it's a complaint from a pum parent was
the cost the cost to the school dish
District so I think if your legislation
were to cover that for these schools I
probably wouldn't have got that phone
call um so I think that that's one of
the concerns among parents is the cost
to the school district so maybe if that
goes hand inand that would alleviate
that
concern that's it thank you very much
welcome uh questions for Miss
Banfield yes repres
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mrs Banfield for coming in front of us
how do you think technology has impacted
the
classroom oh okay so yeah so I did bring
that up um well I think first of all
again I'm not against technology but you
know from day one uh when you know I got
phone calls from parents uh that were
looking at their kids' iPad and finding
naked pictures of other students okay so
that's a problem um you know because
first of all boys can be
charged with uh possessing pornography
if they have a you know if they're
sharing that
information um I had a nurse tell me one
time that she was that when a
child adolescent tries to commit suicide
goes into the a is in the hospital the
nurses have to sit there with that
student and do the if if they're you
know cuz sometimes they can be in the
hospital for a week before they actually
get admitted into the mental health um
institution so they have to sit there if
they're on their iPads and they have to
sit there and watch these kids because
what happens some of them are are like a
a cell phone so they're getting messages
and so there some of the messages is
kill
yourself that's what she told me and
some of the messages that the kids are
in the
hospital for trying to commit suicide
this is the messages that they're
getting on their iPads or Chromebooks
they have to take them because they have
homework to do um a husband of a teacher
told me one time he has to sit with his
daughter to do homework because all she
wants to do is is do YouTube videos
right so he was forced to sit there with
her and do homework maybe we can
restrict restrict it to the to the bill
itself okay all right it's there's only
a couple more the screen time from
optometrist just talk to them mental
health
um yeah so there's problems great thank
you very much you're welcome any further
questions see none thank you uh The
Honorable Wendy
Piper thank you I'm Wendy Piper former
state representative and current
grafting County Commissioner I wasn't
intending to say anything about this
bill today but just my luck uh I came in
because uh I I was at a County
government meeting and I saw the um uh
the bills about uh one superintendent
for instance uh Per County and I thought
my county and ton I went off um and so
uh I saw this bill uh and decided that I
would like to just add a little bit
maybe it's a different perspective
um
so just add I I think I think the
testimony has been so incredibly
informative for me but I'm a lifelong
educator uh college
professor uh and I was asked uh by my
son's High School teacher uh last year
to come in and guest teach uh a course
it did I say English high school English
teacher I was because I'm in English uh
I was asked to come in and guest teach
uh I had a blast I was there for two
weeks and I loved it it was wonderful
but I was
stunned I was stunned at the cell phone
use um my son we'd been in the community
for a long time so everybody knew me and
so you know some students would take out
their cell phone uh and then as soon as
I would look up they would you know
sorry Miss Piper you know that sort of
thing um and I just I guess I just want
to take this from the perspective of a
college professor um that we say that we
want the best for our students uh and
I'm telling you that when our children
get to the college level this is just
simply
unacceptable they there's we don't have
to deal and I mean this very
respectfully because I'm a parent myself
but we don't have to deal with angry
parents we don't have to deal with that
sort of thing you know we're being paid
to Del deliver a product um and to help
our students that in the case of where I
taught uh were paying paying pretty
hefty um uh tuition uh but it's a I I
think it's a tremendous wakeup call for
students when they get to the college
level and and that's why she had asked
me to come in was to give them a slice
of life this is what you can expect next
year and this is not going to be
happening um and so I just wanted to add
that additional information and when I
was in the state house we banned
handheld devices you're
welcome while driving while driving
thank you uh right yes well driving yeah
I'm sorry I'm sorry I was wondering why
nobody said anything I thought I thought
I did a really good job that was
bipartisan folks you you shocked a few
people with that yes yeah I apologize
yeah thank you very much and
questions thank you very much for
sticking
around and Deborah
house okay good afternoon chairman
cordelli I'm glad to be back in front of
the house education policy committee um
I am the President of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
and uh want to say that president Gary
Hoffman uh who spoke onal of the
Nashville teachers union he is president
of our largest uh affiliate in the state
so I glad to hear him um we are here in
support of this proposed Bill we think
Banning cell phone use would be a good
state law to pass to set parameters for
all school districts to adopt local
policies we think it is needed because
not all school districts have adopted
local policies um they should be clear
parameters so that we know what will go
into those policies so we have the
needed exceptions for um students with
disabilities uh you know for those
medical issues where they need to have
the phone for uh you the glucose monitor
or whatever else they have on the phone
um English language Learners who are
using it to help them um you know
because no one else speaks that language
in the school um but the parameters
should be there um but we do think it is
something that would perhaps embolden
maybe some school districts where they
have not yet adopted a policy because
cellones are a distraction in the
classroom you have the whole world right
here and some students can't um manage
their own desire to see what's going on
in the outside world with their friends
it increases their distraction it fuels
their anxiety it is not good for their
their
well-being um yeah they want to know
what they're friends are saying right
now or if they've missed out on a
comment or or something you know
something a friend has said it um it
intensifies conflicts between students
because someone has said something that
they take offense at or has not liked
something that they have posted and it
just it spirals it causes so many
misunderstandings um intensifies
conflicts between students it decreases
peer engagement and communication
because they don't actually talk to each
other during the times when they do have
um social time at school such as lunch
in the hallways so it be really
beneficial for both students and staff
because you would have more of their
focus when you're teaching they'd be
more available to actually learn the
content so for those reasons we support
you passing this to give all of our
school boards the parameters they need
to pass good policies on a local level
and we can give our input in our
communities uh for exactly what well-
defined exceptions they need and uh you
know how to best craft the uh pieces of
the policy that are done at the local
level and that's all I have to say thank
you very much any
questions yes representative Hall thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question do you does the AFT support
Bell to Bell I didn't quite hear the
Bell to bell bell to Bell
um we feel that that could be the most
effective way to do it so that the
students are actually um
socializing with each other you know at
lunchtime and at passing time but again
if you want to leave that to a local
school district decision we will be okay
with that as well um we understand that
you know the the nasua school uh
teachers had a different opinion and
we're more focusing on what's actually
in the
classroom we we could be happy either
way with that but what we really want is
some strong parameters that school
boards have to come up with a policy and
at least limit it in the classroom and
it not be an individual teachers
decision and individual teachers having
to enforce
it follow follow yes um so given that so
the part of the language that says uh
the exception to student use when an
educator is using devices as part of a
lesson plan is that kind of problematic
that that probably shouldn't be there
because now you're going to put one
teacher against another you know some
teacher says oh yeah we're going to use
it today but not really you know just
kind of you would have to have a very
clearly worded policy that says you know
the whole school says the phones can
only be used when it's part of a lesson
plan
so I I guess that would mean the lesson
you would have to like have the lesson
plan in advance something it would have
to be planned in advance it would not be
just happening oh on the spur of the
moment you're all going to have your
phones up but I we all plan in evance
anyway so okay thank you yeah any
further questions see none thank you I
did see represent lfi oh represent
litfield thank thank you and thank you
for taking my question um just related
to what you were just talking about uh
just in the superintendent I mentioned
it as well my concern for lack of a
better way some phones way of putting it
but some people will have phones some
people some people believe it or not
don't have phones I'm wondering in your
opinion wouldn't it make sense just to
strike that completely for instruct you
know what I mean um on a Case by case
basis H let me rephrase that I'm talking
about using it for instructional
purposes because most of the schools
they do have some type of a Chromebook
or an iPad it will have filters for
example to keep out let's say
pornography Etc not all children or kids
have a cell phone or it's not Equitable
in that sense I just don't agree with
them using their personal devices so I'm
wondering if we just strike it all
together what your opinion is on that I
actually agree that they should be using
a school provided device yeah I do not
know if we have sufficiently funded all
of our schools so that they are
providing onetoone Chromebooks so that's
more question on all of
you have you done that
yet and um you've heard me ask this you
know question before um those of you who
have been here have are we sufficiently
funding all of our Public Schools so
that every student in the state is
getting the same robust opportunity for
a public education we really do need to
be doing that because it's not fair for
a student in you know Cold Brook to get
a different education than a student in
in Bedford they're all our Granite State
citizens yeah
thank you very much um appreciate you
being here and
uh that uh ends our day today and uh
since we did a good job you can have
tomorrow off
committee e